[Musique]
oui bonsoir ouais bah oui je vais pas
venir m'écouter
oui au quatrième
qu'est-ce que tu bois
- boit de l'eau tu sais d'habitude donc
je continue de champagne bon je vais pas
le voir mais est ce que tu es j'ai
trompé non je bois jamais d'alcool
bâlois dufry moi on est des cocktails
voilà ça c'est vu un cocktail de jus de
fruits les 30
là dedans je peux
tu vois ça en ce qu'elle pense
j'y croyais pas tu croyais maintenant je
viens d'y croire
après tant d'années peut-être qu'à
barney mais à l'autre mais c'est qu'ils
sont là ils sont embrassés dans
l'ascenseur mais non après 13 ans
ensemble ils continuent à s'embrasser
d'un temps très froid qu'il impose que
nous on connaît pas mais toi tu es avec
ta femme depuis des siècles aussi
oui j'avais que la légende brasse pas
dans les ascenseurs à croire hier j'ai
fait bien je
me sers valence
je suis allé voir sur le tournage ta
carte de police était là il était dans
son carrelage la rue comment ça se passe
est sympa tous les services habituels je
te jure je m'amuse vraiment été dans son
carnage moi je préférerais faire un
grand film mais ça peut arriver que dans
tous les cas quand tu là quand tu l'a
appris il était au fond du trou en bus
tapie n'en ont jamais rien il ya un an
j'avais rien j'ai jamais rien eu
j'avais failli faire tourner dans l'
aventure celle inventée en caleçon et
c'est bien mais rôle d'aldo maccione
away et j'ai failli épouser sa femme
la seule couverture de matches que j'ai
fait c'est avec sa femme mais il a
changé la fin de l'histoire j'ai pris
mes mais attends moi tu vois la preuve
que ça sert à rien de coucher avec un
metteur en scène c'est que moi je ne lis
pas je les pires scénarios on dit et toi
tu mets toi parce que tu chantais guise
on est très content avec les acteurs
clés mais torrent je t'ai toujours bien
l'idée de prendre tapis ce n'est pas une
bonne idée parce que c'est ce que tu es
dans ton bouquin mais comme il avait dit
qu'il avait je sais pas combien de
francs pas rentrer les gens ont dit on
va pas aller voir le film sans un pognon
sa fille ça et ça a été
on n'a pas eu la même analyse tu sais
quand un truc marche
on est toujours à essayer de comprendre
de chercher d'analyser pourquoi ça
marche et quand ça marche pas c'est là
une chose
moi j'ai vu ça dans toutes les
expériences de ma vie quand ça doit
marcher tu peux avoir mis tous les
handicaps contre toi inconnu ça à sa
marque voilà et a imaginé une espèce de
truc on sait pas pourquoi et quand ça
marche pas il ya évidemment cinquante
mille raisons qu'on connaît qui vont
expliquer pourquoi ça va marcher une
émission de télévision pourquoi ça
marche ben oui on sait après coup ça a
marché nous notre film on l'a fait 650
milles la première semaine
six cent cinquante mille la deuxième
semaine 300 et quelques milles la
troisième semaine de 120 et puis il est
mort comme ça on a fini à 1 million 300
mille en plus quand même pas mal ce
qu'ils peuvent dire les gens parlent dit
la première semaine c'était déjà moins
que c'est sur la fiche est bien parce
qu'il a plus spontanément a beaucoup qui
avait envie de le voir est ce qu'ils ont
vu ont pas digne de ce film des choses
qui auraient entraîné je vais au théâtre
si la pièce avait pas plus mais je peux
me plantais si j'étais le même et on a
été plein tout le temps tu deviens
théâtre j'ai fait avec raison c'est une
émission je te jure tu te fais était
bien foutu s'accrochait g j'ai eu beau
changer le décor le sujet je les vois ça
m'a fait peur quand est arrivée d
invitée lundi
ecoute-moi l'audience la première qui
était une merde hein parce qu'on
n'allait pas du temps mais tout
improvisé bon mais néanmoins la première
c'est pas mon avantage ce que je vais
dire mais c'est pour expliquer qu'il ya
une magie situe la remplit pas tu l'a
rendu pas on est à six millions et demi
à 10h30 à l'entrée de l'émission si
mouloungui et là on part dans quel état
avez la courbe a fait ça
à
faire d'abord lui il avait envie qu'on
se tire la bourre tous les deux
parce que le client avait très envie
c'était la seule raison pour laquelle il
a accepté de signer c'était de se dire
qu'un celui là qui est un mâle alpha
beta qu elle
qu un taux de notoriété qui est
totalement anormal et qui est un voyou
je vais tourner avec lui je me demande
dans quelle mesure d'ailleurs lui n'a
pas été capable de le faire signer en
lui disant le coach ça l'aurait pas
dérangée de le faire
et nous voilà partis dans des scènes de
confrontation
et il y en a une qui a effectivement été
alors là pour le coup une improvisation
et elle est improvisé mais lui sait
qu'elle va se passer qui nous prend on
est en voiture
et je suis censé être le mercantile le
co n'a d'ailleurs il a fait toutes les
répliques pour ça mais moi je fais le
con parce que je suis aussi mal
accueillie et donc ça me dérange pas de
jouer le nar alors il lui fait faire des
reprises genre alors que qu'est-ce que
c'est comment comment devient vainqueur
va tu vois des trucs à la con et et
s'imagine en moi je vais dire à le
marchand de télévision tout en gros
c'est lui qui n'y croit ça donc lui il
croit qu'il a un marchand de télévision
et un mec sensible cultiver acteurs et
que et je vais apparaître comme le gros
con maroc télévision tu vois et ça c'est
pas tout à fait passé comme ça parce que
il m'a même sur pascal et moi je l'amène
sur la théorie de pascal et loti faire
c'est énorme comme il n' as complètement
au niveau de la culture générale sauf
les cinq trucs qui l'a appris par coeur
la veille et lui il savait pas ça par
contre mais quand ils voient ça et
jubile et instaurer la ça dure 25
minutes voilà c'est ça c'est rien que la
vérité c'est que il a monté un scénario
il est capable de d'accepter que le
scénario qu'il a monté sa tente et
malade en 20 centièmes de seconde en
version wii non parce que si tu veux je
me régale de voir alors quand elle alors
lui sa réplique s'était alors comme on
fait pour bien vendre alors son
imagination
c'est quand tu veux acheter
tu dis que c'est trop cher et quand tu
veux vendre et quand tu veux vendre tu
dis que c'est vendu toi à moi ce plan là
moi tu qu
il écrit mais les dialogues de tapis
voilà surtout dans ce domaine qui voit
donc là dessus là où c'est formidable et
c'est confortable pour un acteur
ce qu' il faut qu'ils la gagnent sa
place si tu tourner un film avec lelouch
c'est pas sans risque et parce que il
dénature pas la qualité des gens pas
seulement celle d'acteur mais celle de
l'être et c'est ça qui fait chier tous
les autres dans le métier c'est que les
autres dans métier ils sont incapables
incapable de se tourner avec des
metteurs en scène depuis plus que j'en
ai et 5 par an il ya des talentueux des
moins talentueux de près 30 des bons
photographes débauche mais le mec qui
comme le cuisinier à qui tu découvriras
la table il en bave voilà aujourd'hui tu
vois tu es un peu de la rouste t'as un
peu de moutarde latin du safran talus
vin blanc tu as dû et le mec qui sait
pas ce qui va cuisiner alors il a une
idée parce que il sait que ça va être un
repas qui va être pour un mariage à
temps le cahier des charges il est fixé
comme le dit très justement il y a une
histoire et elle est écrite à la rivera
son aboutissement sauf si lui à un
moment du voyage il considère que ce qui
avait projeté ça colle plus que ce
qu'ils voient mais parce que c'est comme
dans la vie
comme je te le disais tout à l'heure
là ce soir on dîne ensemble on a tous
une petite idée on se fait tous un
scénar avant de venir de ce qu'on va
dire de ce qu'on va pas dire de ce qu'on
va se raconter de ce qu'on va vivre mais
c'est vrai que tous les dialogues qu'on
a depuis le début de cette soirée
moi jamais à aucun moment imaginé qu'on
partirait dans cette direction là tu
vois ce que oui alors va-t-il devenir un
héros de série sur tf1 va t-il se
relancer dans la politique va-t-il
reprendre l'om à nouveau tout le monde
en parle voici
[Musique]
désormais
bernard tapie tous ont commencé
mais lui reste comme toi je passe pour
un de ses poids bonne pourtant
[Musique]
bernard tapie bonsoir bonsoir vous
connaissez laurent baffie et comment
tient là j'ai un truc pour toi vous êtes
vu à la première de canal j'ai fait un
cadeau ouais mais n'a pas bravo a parlé
tout à l'heure dans la loge celle
d'origine parce que moi je l'avais
signer et faire et c'est celle d'origine
je les garde voilà vous êtes libéré de
prison voilà c'est une carte c'est une
carte du monopoly et non vinci avait
offert un verre dans sa fille à l'école
laurent
et le petit chat canal et oui bernard
bonsoir vouthon telle aventure sur une
chaîne une chaîne du câble s'appelle rtl
9 ans l'émission s'appelle rien à cacher
c'est le dimanche à 19h20 donc et vous
interviewer une personnalité tous les
dimanches rtl 9 vous êtes sûr bernard
tapie que c'est pas pour des raisons
fiscales que vous et non parce que c'est
une société française avant parce qu'on
le siège est à paris bon vous êtes à
domicile et en belgique en ce moment non
j'aurais bien voulu mais parce qu'il
paraît que vous recevez du courrier à
vous et merci c'est vrai puisque
restèrent la vérité 1 3 rond point de
l'étoile à ixelles c'est dans la
banlieue de bruxelles chez le bourg mais
ce qui s'appelle yves de jonghe d'ardoye
d'erp qu'un vicomte il paraît que vous
recevez du courrier chez lui non c'est
parce que j'ai été député européen
pendant longtemps et quand on est député
européen on habite au moins trois jours
par semaine en belgique à dakar et donc
j'habitais là bas et c'est ce qui fait
que j'ai une adresse belge et que j'ai
un lieu de résidence belge ne sut pas
résident dans la mesure où poids à ce
statut vous le savez le fisc impose
iphone oui on est plus de sens eu plus
de 160 jours par an voilà donc moi dans
ma peau verte a rebâti d'accord vous
êtes des avoirs à l'étranger parce que
tout le monde là on va être mon désir
tout voir est-ce que tapie il aurait pas
à l'étranger des comptes match at il
seulement j'en ai pas mais bien sûr
c'est pas seulement j'en ai pas peur
[Applaudissements]
bernard sérieux sérieusement ils ont
tellement cherché le tellement tellement
tellement parce que ça leur faisait
plaisir or il ya un truc que je
comprends pas vous avez plein d'ennuis
et vous avez toujours votre hôtel
particulier le dessin terne au moment
c'est une occupation à la fois partiel
est momentanée mais en fait la famille
de la pinatelle particulier à la maison
[Musique]
en fait j'ai aperçu pour arriver avec
trish quand tu pars de canal c'est long
il ya un temps de réponse très long mais
pour être pauvre quand on ne croit
riesch s'est lui aussi laissé des
membres
des riches et des pauvres à la hâte en
je suis probablement dans un statut
fiscal unique au monde unique au monde
parce que aujourd'hui j'ai de décrire la
situation quand je gagne 1000 francs
dois je le dis elle a déjà joué avant
qui parle pognon c'est très malin de
mettre le plus de l'abbé pierre
c'est dit
la td gueula ce parce que c'est pas la
meilleure du coup c'est la soeur thérésa
alors tu te souviens pas tu te souviens
pas que
on va parler en anciens francs pour ma
fille pendant servant même pour ma mère
alors sans sac ouais là quand tu gagnes
sont sacrés bons les impôts normal près
de 50% ça fait cinquante comme jeu sur
liquidation des biens ils prennent 30
puisque je donne un tiers à la
liquidation donc je gagne 100 francs
j'ai 50 francs qui va officier crayon et
4 et 30 francs non mais les suivent
hélas 20 francs il reste un point bas
fils alban tant pis vrai groupe
seulement maintenant comme les douanes
mon fils et une amende en 95 parce que
j'ai été assez qu'on mette mon bateau
sous pavillon français a tendance aussi
prenez les vins français rien et tu vois
c'est vachement mieux il faut que tous
les français qui écoute là ils se
rendent compte qu'on est dans un pays de
malades quand je gagne 1000 maintenant
les doigts me prennent les villes
rajouter 4 0 de bananes d'abord et après
je paye 500 way au fisc et 300 avec cet
accord tiens je suis le seul mec au
monde chaque fois je gagne un peu
d'argent je dois beaucoup d'argent
puisque je crois c'est vrai les vins
qu'ils me prennent non ça n'appelle
alors attendre non mais attends parce
qu'à la limite le cumul des différentes
lois fait que tout le monde à un moment
donné vous en savez quelque chose peut
avoir affaire à eux ce qui est
construite à des tanks et les uns et le
sel c'est le 7 août à valence et à 5 ans
j'ai eu un contrôle qui s'est finie
vachement bien un bon gars qui
connaissaient déjà et je connaissais
strauss kahn j'ai filé des cassettes
pornos
là là où c'est pas là où c'est pas bien
et là où je pense que je vais me fâcher
et pour de vrai attention c'est que
quand mon syndic et mon avocat arrive et
bio douanes m'attendais c'est une dette
de 95 il ya donc l'argent cash la
la land vous pouvez vous faire payer
cash ça les a pas intéressé autrement
dit là c'est plus dans le sens de
l'intérêt du public puisque l'intérêt du
public c'est toucher l'argent ouais là
plutôt que de toucher les 5 millions
d'âmes en cash ils préfèrent aller
m'emmerder sur mes cachets de rtl9 vol
au-dessus d'un nid de coucou de comédien
alors pourquoi on vous a saisi
effectivement vos salaires de comédiens
vos cachets de comédiens survol au
dessus d'un nid de coucou vos cachets
d'animateur sur la haine c'est est-ce
que c'est l'histoire du fossé ans et les
6 millions de francs que vous devez pour
le e55 pourquoi parce que vous l'avez
mis sous pavillon français ou le domaine
sous pavillon panaméen non parce que je
cassais
peu prudent parce qu'en fait je crois
que c'est pas de la volonté de
s'extraire à l'impôt que les gens
mettent leur bateau sous un pavillon
étranger c'est parce que les normes de
la marine marchande française sont
devenus tellement contraignantes
qu'elles sont pratiquement plus
applicable ce plan judiciaire vin et où
bernard pasquet toujours un procès en
cours pour banqueroute et détournements
d'actifs qui bloque en fait la procédure
c'est votre procédure vous d' attaques
contre le crédit lyonnais c'est qu'en
fait vous avez déclenché une action
contre le crédit lyonnais vous pouvez
gagner beaucoup d'argent non parce que
c'est sur la vente d'adidas si on gagne
vous êtes de nouveau très très riche
je vais récupérer ce qu'on m'a pris je
fais beaucoup d'argent ça peut faire
beaucoup en fait ce que vous dites c'est
que l'histoire d'adidas vous que
racontez nous la faire parce que c'est
intéressant comment vous vous êtes fait
spolier dans cette histoire d'adidas
nommé se faire spolier dans le monde des
affaires il n'y a pas de quoi se faire
plaindre il m'est arrivé de deux roulés
dans la farine et me faire rouler dans
la farine c'est une des règles du monde
des affaires à condition qu'on reste
dans les règles ce qui est pas tolérable
c'est quand vous donnez un mandat de
vente à un banquier pour vendre un de
vos actifs qui vous prétend l'avoir
vendu 2 milliards et qu'en fait le même
jour il a revendu quatre et demi cent à
dire on dit ça c'est pas bien pourquoi
le faire alors si c'est une banque le
mineur etc sans importance on peut se
dire avant ses dégoûts niafs mais dès
lors que c'est une grande banque
nationalisée avec à la tène les gens
importants et compétents on est en droit
de dire c'est un abus ce serait aux
états unis la vente est nulle ah ouais
bon c'est vrai que si la nouvelle
aujourd'hui adidas reviens chez moi ça
vaut 35 milliards c'est bien je vais
vous donner un autre chiffre marquant
ils m'ont vendu les actions d'adidas de
tf1 100 millions un cheval 4 milliards
donc c'est pour vous dire que j'ai et le
tribunal actuellement depuis cinq ans on
cherche à savoir si on va le juger ou si
on va pas le juger c'est les lenteurs
des procédures et alors tu es plus vite
pour me coller en taule pour un match de
football oui
[ __ ] y en a qui ça va bien il y en a
qui savent à moi même chaîne le faire
bon
alors donc la pilule c'est pas mon truc
vol au-dessus d'un nid de coucou en
tournée et rtl9 vettel dimanche série
marche là à 19h20 sur rtl9 kravitz et
c'est qui santoni sans évidemment bien
alors et puis attendez la up attention
il ya l'om
lycées picdi la [ __ ] là ça fait mal
big deal alors là moi je crois qu'on est
bon vous savez pardon d'abord on va
faire un petit flashback au mba pour
vous c'était le début de la fin sinon
c'était le déclic dans votre vie c'était
le début de la fin ça a été le prétexte
le prétexte voilà on vous début il ya
belle lurette le plus c'est quand je
fais 12 % aux européennes près faux
après bon après il faut arrêter ça ça
aurait pu être de la cam dans mon coffre
ça aurait pu être n'importe quoi qui est
élevé à il y avait mellick la semaine
dernière il est génial on l'a raconté
son livre j'ai pas eu le temps de line
mais il est génial parce qu' ils
racontent une histoire apparemment
toujours la même et il a je crois fini
par y croire alors je vais simplement
dire à mon ami mellick que j'adore parce
que c'est vraiment un mec qui a du coeur
des fidèles que si j'avais été quoi que
ce soit quoi que ce soit dans la
construction de son faux témoignage
j'aurais été un peu inquiété pour faux
témoignage ou complicité de faux
témoignages et bien alors maintenant
d'un tapis sérieusement vous êtes
juridiquement mesure de demander une
licence de dirigeant de club auprès de
la ligue oui parce qu'elle devra en plus
je vais même vous en apprendre une cape
qui est passé à côté mais la ligue a été
condamné pour me l'avoir retiré et il
n'avait pas le droit de me la retirer ça
veut dire qu'il ya quand même mal géré
et il ya des juristes qui sont allés un
peu cherché voir et qui se sont pas
contentés de l'histoire du sac enterrés
dans le jardin et qui fait qu'après le
conseil d'état estimé en confirmant que
je devais avoir le droit d'avoir une
licence alors robert louis dreyfus il
voulait pas partir maintenant ils
partiraient là je sais pas en tout cas
il a dépensé beaucoup d'argent pour
poserait sur yon pour peu de résultats
600 millions vous aviez mis 60 millions
ouais une amie 600 millions et 10 et
l'émirat c'est vrai qu'il a gagné dans
la ddh à ce bon
donc une amie généreux avec le brouillon
des deux lui l'ami 600 millions avec ses
600 millions finalement il n'est pas
arrivé à floréal bien que vous avec 60
ben oui bah oui c'est un métier ça mais
alors est-ce que voulez vous aider
robert louis dreyfus ah ah ah ah non
regardez le club lui ça mon son sort
m'intéresse pas ce qui m'intéresse c'est
là c'est le sort de l'om ouais et
uniquement ça alors vous votez à
marseille par la tête mais
domicilié ou la non mais c'est à
l'époque où j'étais simplement
conseiller régional conseiller
départemental et donc forcément les
j'habitais marseille j'étais député des
bouches du rhône étaient toujours
électeurs à marseille
alors votre vie commence par une
incertitude en fait la première
incertitude c'est sur votre naissance
des dès le début il y avait déjà les
incertitudes avec vous bah oui je vous
est née sept mois après le mariage de
vos parents
il ya deux solutions
soit vous soit vous êtes en plus non
plus ainsi c'est pas vrai ah si j'ai
commencé le 26 janvier quarante-trois
voilà et vos parents sont mariés en
juillet donc ça fait sept mois mais
pendant quarante-trois vous êtes dans
son entier 43 vos parents vous ont conçu
si vous ont conçu en juillet 42 vous
êtes né à sept mois prématuré je suis né
v6 en faute et avant le mariage aura
dépassionner le débat sur la burqa les
jours le lundi 10 le la différentes
affiches tu la
perds je ne crois tout à fait capables
d'avoir séduit maman est comme ça fait
maintenant 60 ans qui sont mariés
ensemble on peut éventuellement leur
pardonner d'avoir fait l'amour ou de
moelle et les deux mois voilà donc est
là moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est
exactement la formation d'octave
caractère comment vous êtes devenu
bernard tapie alors quand vous êtes né
votre père était au st lô en allemagne
jeudi pour nos amis qu'on pas connu ça
si le service du travail obligatoire
tiers qu'on en prenait des français
pourrait travailler en allemagne il ya
beaucoup de jeunes communistes de jeunes
ouvriers communistes qui avaient été
emmenés en allemagne au west et au et
notamment georges marchais ils étaient
partis travailler chez messerschmidt
alors votre père jean tapie était
ouvrier jean baptiste mois et affiche
non
et moi je crois que votre problème vient
de là c'est à dire que finalement votre
père non non les états qui est tu vas
écoute moi tu vas voir car ton problème
j'ai même pas ton problème parce que je
vais d'excusés dans deux minutes et
tu es gentil l'or bat je pense d'un
problème de deep moi
non mais sérieux évidemment non voilà je
vous dire pourquoi vous le savez
d'ailleurs votre père lui c'est un le
bon ouvrier le bon ouvrier communiste le
vrai quoi tient le type qui est dur à la
tâche qui veut s'élever socialement mais
à force de travail
du tout pourquoi pas du tout pas du tout
son père était drag queen amis l'ouvrier
mon père symbole ouvriers commerce l'un
fait qui est honnête sérieux
c'est pas militant politique du meriva
qui les militants politiques jeudi que
lui pour lui le travail s'est il veut
s'élever dans la hiérarchie sociale tout
vous à travers le travail il veut il
veut travailler pour nourrir ses membres
il fait en dix heures par semaine quand
des bernard quand il va louzine la
journée que le soir il va à l'école des
arts et métiers s'élever socialement pas
du tout c'est pour avoir du boulot et
nourrir sa famille le vrai problème
c'est votre père c'est quelqu'un de très
rigoureux et vous voulez que je vous le
dise après voyez dire et si c'est ça n'a
rien à voir à ça quand vous êtes né dans
un milieu qui soit peu importe on va pas
faire du misérabilisme
il ya plein de mômes qui sont très
malheureux d'être dans milieu de bourges
par exemple c'est quand vous êtes dans
un milieu et que l'environnement de ce
milieu ne vous plaît pas quel que soit
le milieu en question vous vous révoltez
d'une manière ou d'une autre il ya plein
de monde qui sont bourrés qui se foutent
dans des mouvements trotskistes ya
quatre ans parce qu'il supporte étoile
et moi je ne supporte pas ce milieu
parce que c'est un milieu totalement
totalement soumis qui répond à rien et
de d'aucune manière à toutes les
agressions vont leur fait et à partir du
jour je deviens un étudiant je vais à
paris et donc je suis en contact de
mômes qui viennent d'ailleurs il ya à la
fois une révolte de ma part de voir ces
injustices car mon père est intelligent
il est travailleur il bosse seulement il
a baigné toute sa vie dans un milieu qui
lui permet pas de ces lois là et cette
injustice là me fait chier à voilà ça
rien à voir avec un complexe d'oedipe
l'on attend dé votre père c'est
quelqu'un d'assez j'ai une vraie bagarre
social vous êtes d'une famille unie
vraiment vous êtes une famille où on
n'est pas très expansif votre terre est
plutôt renfermé vous êtes plutôt hâbleur
plutôt expansif justement et vous voyez
votre père travailler jour et nuit et
finalement être traitée plutôt pas très
bien et vous vous dites pour réussir il
ya sûrement des raccourcis à prendre et
ça a été et ça a été la raison de votre
opposition à votre père jour oppose jour
je n'explique la deuxième partie la
première partie on a compris pourquoi
des gosses pour sortir de leur milieu
font des efforts un peu surhumain alors
après il est question effectivement du
parcours qui est un parcours chaotique
sur lequel de temps en temps il ya une
ligne on franchit on la franchit pas ça
c'est autre chose ça vient de deux
phénomènes bien connu le premier c'est
que on connaît personne et on connaît
pas les règles et c'est capital moi je
vois mon fils y fait son site trois
jours après il à l'avocat qui a déjà
pris un expert contact j'aurais pas moi
je connais aucune règle aucune règle
mais pas d affaire aucune règle qui
permettent à quelqu'un de s'élever dans
la société donc je les invente et quand
vous les inventer vous êtes un parcours
initiatique vous faites des parcours bon
et des parcours mauvaise ya personne
pour vous dire là c'est bien là c'est
pas bien donc vous découvrez au fur et à
mesure l'itinéraire que vous devez
prendre on est d'accord mais 22e le 2e
etc est aussi une des raisons du
handicap si vous vous apercevez qu'on
n'a pas envie vous changer de catégorie
vous êtes bien là où ils assurent les
accords alors mais je suis d'accord avec
vous ce que je vous dis simplement c'est
que votre père lui il avait une vision
assez soumises effectivement des choses
vous vous dites c'est pas possible je
vais prendre des raccourcis je suis un
homme je suis révolté salars avec les
raccourcis et nerveux je me suis par
exemple jamais permis jamais le car mais
pas le quart 10% vous savez tirer en le
jugeant
à 10 dans un bouquin tapis à côté des
grands arnault pinault c'est un enfant
de choeur
parce que j'ai pas fait 10% bien sûr
parce que je n'étais pas du même milieu
social au départ bien sûr mais je
reproche rien à voir avec le raccourci à
cette je vous revois je vous reproche
parlera qu'on sait c'est qu'il est matin
peinture et dangereux des chauriens qui
laisserait supposer c'est pour quelques
jeux pas laisser ce bout raccourcis
souris soit le mot raccourci laisserait
supposer qu'on n'hésite pas de franchir
les règles pour aller plus vite c'est
pas ça du tout mais vous dites je
connaissais pas les règles toute façon
mais je leur accorde mais c'est vrai que
votre père lui il avait une vision
plutôt traditionnel de la réussite
l'accumulation du travail du temps passé
et d'ailleurs vous est jamais arrivé à
l'impressionner votre père c'est à dire
qu'il a toujours été votre réussite il a
vécu comment il a vécu comme quelque
chose les rues vous mais ça va pas il
était heureux à chaque fois et moi pour
le séduire j'étais content j'étais en
équipe de france juniors de handball il
venait voir tous les matches je faisais
des concerts de viol on y venait
assister au concert à ses actionnaires
vous amis aux violences qui était
prémonitoire
c'est pas bien ça
j'aime bien avant fit et que je suis
faible et que des 10700 le défendre
alors
donc je dis ben je dis qu'il faut pas
les parents mes parents ont eu une vertu
c'est de me donner et de m'apprendre
l'essentiel et je les en remercie dans
la mesure où c'est l'essentiel qui m'a
permis de tenir l'expression a terminé
là dessus mais pourquoi votre père quand
il a monté ça fait des années 60 vous
chercher du boulot pourquoi vous a
jamais engagé c'est bien parce que j'ai
un problème avec lui mais pas du tout il
faisait des camions réfrigérés et il a
embauché mon frère vous êtes dans ce
milieu je dis pas que ces causes est un
vous avez un appartement au bourget dans
ses premiers étages bin voila je dis
simplement qu'à un moment vous avez
décidé de trahir classes sociales parce
que c'est une façon mais c'est pas
reproche c'est une façon de la volaille
et vous en sortir une vraie question
d'ailleurs allé poser souvent à ceux qui
comme moi change est-ce que c'est
l'exemplarité de votre réussite qui est
positive et qui peut donner envie à
d'autres de dire c'est possible donc on
va le faire il ya eu le cas est-ce que
c'est au contraire une manière
totalement irréel et j'allais dire
insultante de faire croire des jantes
sont des imbéciles puisqu'ils le font
pas il ya eu qu'à aussi donc comme tous
les symboles et quand vous faites des
choses un peu qui sortent de l'ordinaire
vous symbolique bah j'ai eu ma part de
bons exemples j'ai été positif et utile
à certains et j'ai été une catastrophe
pour d'autres c'est ce qui fait que dans
ce pays les gens qu'ils m'adorent et des
gens qui me détestent lorsque je dis
simplement c'est qu'à l'époque quand
vous allez au bord de la marne à la fin
des vacances avec votre mère votre frère
c'était non mais c'était génial à vous
souffriez génial à fleurir et dans la
main visiblement qu'à un moment vous
vous dis c'est pas c'est bon là la vraie
vie c'est pas ça et pour s'en sortir
quand même dans votre cahier de solution
il ya la boxe où le rock'n'roll et vous
avez choisi la chanson c'est pour ça que
j'ai voulu changer le défunt au dessus
ne s'est pas fait mieux c'est pas mieux
mais pas mieux c'est pas salé téméraire
voulez pas vous sortir de votre classe
sociale est venu chercher maintenant je
suis laissé dire aux gens de sortir de
la soumission c'est à dire quand je
n'ose pas vous le dire parce que je vais
encore être un mauvais exemple mais je
considère que par exemple voilà la
manière dont un représentant de la force
publique parle un ouvrier dans sa
voiture qui rit un feu rouge m
insupportable et maintenant il me parle
plus de cette façon là et je suis
content qu'il me parle plus de cette
façon oui et j'aurais aimé qu'ils
parlent pas de cette façon là mon père
qui disait rien quand on le faisait on
est d'accord
votre premier boulot c'est quoi j'ai
vendu des téléviseurs est génial
c'était génial parce que c'est une
époque où il y en avait pas et donc
j'avais convaincu le gars qui était venu
pour me vendre 1 que s'il les prêtait
avec une antenne pendant quelques jours
il ya de grandes chances qu'ils auraient
pu envie de le laisser repartir il m'a
dit tu crois on en a mis 12 ans un
camion et sept minutes après les doses
étaient placés les gens qui sortaient de
la wii aux moi j'en veux aussi moi j'en
venais aussi et puis file en huit jours
après avec est-ce que c'était pas déjà
une façon de piéger les gogos ça je sais
pas s'ils ont un téléviseur le laisser
pendant huit jours en disant attendre au
fener vous disiez passable dernière
l'institut de sondage ont fait des
études sur la tv donc on vous laisse le
téléviseur peut voir ce que vous pensez
des programmes
sait qu'il ne peut pas l'accuser d'être
un mauvais vendeurs de à ça non mais je
la
connais des vendeurs qui te vendent un
truc qui te disent regarder l'écran dans
30 ans j'y suis
chapeau noter
[Applaudissements]
qu'elles peuvent aujourd'hui après
toutes ces aventures pas fini le
bouillonnement aujourd'hui je parle à
moi je ne sais pas faire un bilan un
moment donné de la vie parce que à 48
heures près tu vois imagine je gagne mon
procès contre le lyonnais dans quinze
jours quand on se revoit je suis pas le
même que si je le perds ouais bah quand
on se revoit vous achetez tout la france
deux mois lui tout le monde en jachère
est pas moins vous achetez plus nom du
pot de colle sérieusement
vous avez vous êtes a suivi toujours les
conseils de votre père et mon père il
n'est pas prétentieux au point de
vouloir me donner des conseils dès lors
que je quittais le chemin qu'il avait
lui-même parcouru le conseil s'est quand
même pas abstrait c'est mon expérience
me permet de te dire attention fais pas
ça mon père dès lors que je quitte la
maison je fais des choses réelles vert
il avait une autre façon que vous de
voir les choses totalement
il est discret il est modeste il est de
il est il est
réfléchi à tous les temps tous les sens
du terme il est manuel il est capable de
fabriquer n'importe quoi moi non on est
on est pas pareil avant ça je peux avoir
la lumière là
avant de quitter ce sujet
est ce que vous dites pas à sérieusement
des fois sérieusement encore et c'est
pas maintenant parce que vous allez bien
ça marche mais quand vous étiez en cage
comme vous dites vous n'êtes pas l'idée
fois j'aurais mieux fait d'écouter mon
père mon père avait raison
bien mal acquis ne profite jamais ce
genre de choses qu'on se dit donc j'ai
déjà l'impression d'avoir mal acquis
et vous êtes jamais dit mon père avait
raison non finalement sa vie à lui qui
est humble qui est une vie simple et
humble finalement j'aurais été plus
heureux si j'avais accepté cette villa
non mais attendez je vais vous expliquer
quelque chose il a été très heureux avec
maman way qui depuis
60 ans et sa femme où on a fêté ensemble
190 m oui mais vous vous êtes pas
attendre suivi saphir ouais moi ça fait
28 ans que je suis avec la mienne je
suis aussi heureux que lui réclame
sienne rêve malgré le parcours très
différents or comme mon bonheur conjugal
compte autant que lui et que ma vie
perdre professionnel compte après et que
j'ai pas eu de rater de ce côté là je
suis très heureux c'était la question
qui tue
non
vient alors maintenant dans cette
émission le public n'est pas là que pour
faire ça il peut aussi poser des
questions qui me poser des questions à
faire un tapis vous là mais ici c'est un
moyen de rencontrer des filles on nous
appelait comment karine karine je vais
vous poser une question ça vous arrive
de pleurer pour de vrai
cette évidence
évidemment et quand tu aller en prison
je vous fais une confidence je m'y étais
préparé puisque je les suis trois mois
al avance je m'étais vraiment préparés
parce qu'on m'avait dit fais du training
c'était donc je mettais aménagé en bas
dans ma call un lieu totalement noire
sans fenêtre sans rien et j'y faisais
des petits morceaux de la préventive et
j'étais certain d'arriver à subir
l'épreuve sans aucun doute et j'avais
dit en partant
j'avais dit ça va se passer comme une
lettre à la poste et deux heures et
demie après tu vois pas huit mois après
deux heures et demie après quand le faux
bond c'est fermé j'ai vu mon fils qui
m'a vu monter et malheureusement lui mme
boyer plus et moi à travers les grilles
je voyais mon fils et mon fils et push
pencher sur son volant et s'est mis à
pleurer lui et l'âge était par terre
donc je croyais avoir être capable de
tenir lui moi j'ai tenu deux heures et
demie merci
vous appelez comme en amérique ou qui je
la reconnais oui c'est vrai chantier un
truc est sûr c'est qu'on a reconnu un
mois c'est pour les petits shorts mieux
c'est marc d
ceci dit et le t-shirt mouillé il ya
longtemps qu'on me l'a fait là venant de
toi je m'attendais à mieux quand même
assisté à la remise
koki la dernière fois que tu es venu à
déclencher une guerre avec madame de
fontenay donc aujourd'hui on sera
schiste est confiant je les ai regardés
par un gâteau non plus ta caisse
justement je vais essayer de ne pas
profiter de votre faiblesse puisque on
en parlait tout à l'heure vous le grand
charmeur le beau parleur trois mois et
demi de prison sans femmes à six mois
alors pardon alors c'est pire justement
100 femmes est-ce que c'était pas trop
dur
comme tout le monde j'ai regardé canal+
la prochaine pub c'est canal+ la chaîne
des branleurs les y pense il travaille
là dessus
[Musique]
vient alors maintenant on va faire une
interview dans la peau d'un autre
[Musique]
on ne bouge pas dans le jean gala avoir
commencé la dj renvoie le jingle non
parce qu attendez je vais dire un truc
avant de renvoyer de jingle je savais
pas vous avez bougé oui il ya une fille
qui me dit elle me dit est ce que chez
nous elle m'envoie un email est-ce que
chez nous aussi on doit pas bouger
pendant le jingle ben je dis oui bien
sûr un temps mais qu'est ce que c'est ça
mais alors y en a une qui vit alors y en
a une autre qui s'appelle corps d'un
homme qui dit mais en allant didier elle
maintenant je tiens à dire ça parce
qu'effectivement d'abord à la maison ne
doit pas bouger par le jingle comme ici
et elle dit c'est pas possible de
baisers pendant tout le monde en parle
parce que toutes les trois minutes faut
lever la main pour la promo où il faut
pas bouger pendant le jingle je sais
c'est compliqué en grèce les trucs comme
apaisé le sanwi passe des trucs ne la
comprend pas pour faire compliqué donc
on y retourne didier on ne bouge pas
pendant les deux guerres
[Musique]
voilà c'est pas compliqué répond pas un
jour y aura des manifestations tueur
atterrés
alors on va jouer à un jeu donc c'est
dans la peau d'un autre c'est une
nouvelle interview dont vous êtes dans
la peau de chirac par exemple je réponds
comme il devrait répondre selon moi ou
comme je pense qu'ils répondraient lui
avoue répondait comme vous pensez qu'ils
répondraient lui 1 alors si je vous dis
par exemple comme alliot-marie vous est
expliqué sur la cassette jacques chirac
que je vois pas pourquoi on continue à
vous embêter
c'est tout à fait vrai ouais vous pensez
que vous êtes expliqué ben oui puisque
j'y vis j'y étais pour rien et je suis
respectueux de la fonction et je suis
président de la république sans
conneries sur cette cassette jeudi je me
suis expliqué si vous êtes de nouveau
chirac je vous dis qu'il ya une rumeur
sur votre santé que vous êtes un peu
comme pompidou à l'époque d'alain kick
un peu grossi parce que vous prenez de
la cortisone alors c'est la cortisone ou
la bière dont vous avez vu je suis parti
en vacances avec avec ma femme est en
hausse à lyon on a bouffé
[Applaudissements]
je sais pas moi qui l'aï là c'est vrai
il a dû se laisser aller ouais vous
pensez que c'est la picole et la bouffe
ouais je crois bien alors imaginez vous
soyez jospin
et je vous dis que vous avez fait douze
pages dans gala cette semaine
est ce que c'est si malin que ça à
lionel de montrer le luxe dans lequel
vous vivez à matignon même si sandra et
blanc écoutez on n'arrête pas de me dire
que finalement je suis très intelligent
pas chirac ouais je suis très performant
pas schirrhein que je suis
travailleur pas chirac et tous les
sondages le donnent perdant face à
chirac quand je demande à mes
conseillers pourquoi on me dit parce
qu'ils y ont joués à tout le monde qu'il
a une bonne grille qui sourit oui du
bombe a fait moi sourire c'est plus
facile de faire des ravages je vous
dirais lionel que chirac et touche le
cul des vaches c'est que vous vous
apprêtez à partir des quignons dans un
luxe de palace mais je suis pas au bout
après je commence par ça d'accord mais
je vais finir dans le pré dès 20h
d'accord ça va très bien vous êtes de
nouveau chirac vous allez tuer jus comme
enjeu spa avant 2002 je vais tuer
comment jospin en 2002 jacques
ça va pas être facile
comment vous allez faire je vais lui
proposer de prendre debré comme ministre
vous en sortez bien jacques et vous
lionel commence à s'habituer chirac en
je vais demander à ma garde des sceaux
de continuer de ne pas s'occuper des
affaires comme elle s'en occupe pas
voici la table
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bernard tapie bonsoir
alors c'est bien bernard le plus les
heures de la bande
147 millions d'euros le 30 septembre
2005 la cour d'appel de paris a rendu
justice pour avoir dissimulé la vérité
sur les conditions d'achat et de revente
d'adidas la banque devra payer
147 millions d'euros à bernard tapie
mais la nuit
[Applaudissements]
on vous voit revenir comme ça là c'est
un peu le comte de monte cristo quoi
c'est à dire que vous revenez vous avez
raison schwarzy abibac a levé la
bon
ballon dans ma main il a fallu attendre
le mandat oui alors ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est que votre version
de la sphère en fait vous n'aviez
données bernard tapie dans un livre
publié en 1998 chez plon qui s'appelle
librement et que vous ressortez
aujourd'hui avec un avant-propos mais
sans avoir rien changer du livre sauf
qu'à l'époque personne s'ils étaient
vraiment intéressés vous en avez vendu
100 milles mais voyait pas été ça aide à
retourner l'opinion disant voilà non
mais parce que c'était pas le sens de
l'histoire et qu'à cette époque n'avait
pas envie d'entendre une autre version
que celle qui était connue de tous c'est
à dire c'est un brigand c'est un voyou
il a pas de morale etc et quand on est
dans cette situation là c'est très
compliqué d'arriver à renverser la
tendance et même si on l'écrit et même
si on fait des émissions de télévision
dans ces circonstances là je me souviens
avoir fait une émission avec un type que
tech est un bon animateur ténue et non
c'était celui qui remplaçait anne
sinclair sur ses fils de michel field on
n'avait vraiment pris notre temps et
j'avais expliqué des trucs quoi j'avais
sorti les papiers j'avais dit regardez
ça fait depuis 96 que la première
sanction est déjà tombé et à la fin de
l'émission on a fait des tests et les
gens disaient ah c'est un escroc mais
l'effort
cécile est bon c'est ça il est vraiment
bon ça voyous mais il est vachement bon
alors dans cet avant propos que vous
avez rajouté pour l'art publication de
ce livre d'un tapis vous dit évidemment
un bon j'ai gagné deux je veux quand
même rendre justice à la justice de mon
pays c'est toujours évidemment une bonne
nouvelle quand on apprend que au delà de
la morale et des envies d'aller dans le
goût du plain nombre des magistrats
regarde le droit et la haine ne se
contente que d'appliquer le droit c'est
vrai vous dites dans cet avant propos
que c'est le contribuable qui va payer
deux euros chacun mais que vous avez
fait gagné tellement d'argent non mais
je dis le contraire
je dis qu'il va pas payer je lis qu'il a
la chance de ne pas avoir un froid à
sortir sur cette affaire dans la mesure
où un plus de francs c'est une partie du
bénéfice
non mais c'est une partie du bénéfice
qu'ils ont encaissés oui c'est bien ce
que je vous dis pas et deuxièmement ça
va même pas coûté le franc question car
ça a été provisionnée depuis très
longtemps oui voyez ce que je veux dire
c'est un c'est de l'argent qu'ils ont
gagné en trop donc ils me rendent un
petit bout met en garde deux fois plus
que moi dans le vin oui et contribuables
ils ont gagné 600 millions d'euros le
voilà donc les braves alors vous en
voulez bernard tapie à ceux qui vous ont
ruiné bien entendu à ce que comme vous
dites qu'ils ont fabriqué votre faillite
mais aussi au relais d'opinion qui n'ont
pas tenu compte du contenu du livre lors
de sa parution et quand on lit votre
avant-propos vous rappeler que dit 1996
le tribunal de commerce avait jugé qu'il
y avait un préjudice financier
considérable et ensuite depuis dix ans
en fait si le crédit lyonnais qui a fait
traîner devant les avocats ont fait leur
boulot en faisant ce que beaucoup de
gens font c'est à dire gagner du temps
et c'est un des problèmes de la justice
française s'est très souvent les
procédures sont longues elles sont plus
que contradictoires elles permettent de
faire des sursis à statuer de faire des
expertises en fait tout le monde sait
que les grandes affaires judiciaires en
france en matière si vince et disant
ceci étant et nous ont fait perdre 10
ans de votre vie quand même oui alors on
perd pas mais en tout cas ils m'ont fait
vivre une vie n'aurait pas été la même
mais bon j'ai vécu des moments un peu un
peu compliqué voilà ça c'est ce que vous
avez rajouté dans le la nouvelle version
du livre c'est l'avant propos pour le
reste vous l'avez laissé tel quel vous
ne l'avez pas corrigé mais c'est vrai
que quand on se lit ce livre maintenant
depuis votre victoire contre le crédit
lyonnais ça prend un nouveau relief
alors ça commence quand vous êtes
condamné à huit mois ferme dans la
sphère au mba vous allez en prison et
vous raconter c'est assez poignant
d'ailleurs vous racontez votre départ je
voulais absolument donner enfin j'avais
envie de lutter quoi j'avais envie de
leur dire vous allez pas en plus vous
faire le plaisir de me faire du mal dont
je m'étais entraîné pendant presque
quinze jours je mettais foutu dans la
cave huit heures par jour je m'étais dit
tu vas apprendre à être solitaire et
c'est donc pas femme est partie elle n'a
pas voulu vivre mon arrestation
julie va la partie avec les enfants
sports d'hiver et seul stéphane est
resté avec moi et j'étais absolument
convaincu en lui disant tu verras il va
rien m'arriver ne fais pas de bile et
mme truc de chance quand j'arrive dans
la cour du palais de justice qui va
mettre dans le fourgon stéphane m'avait
suivi avec son scooter et au moment où
je monte dans le four bon ils voient pas
que je le vois et s'écroule le pauvre et
là tu vois ton gosse qui est en larmes
donc en fait j'ai tenu une demi heure
kwh est avant que ça soit dur ouais
alors vous mais à la prison de la santé
régime d'isolement et vous décidez la de
vous nourrir de l'ordinaire de ne pas
faire d'achats supplémentaires
pas de somnifères pas de tranquillisants
pas d'anti dépresseurs et vous décidez
de vous évader par la pensée il ya un
truc assez joli c'est que tous les soirs
à 22h vous avez rendez vous avec votre
femme est ce que ce qui est par contre
dommage c'est qu'on n'a jamais réussi à
avoir le même rendez vous on s'invente
est un rendez vous ouais à poil sur un
lit tranquille les yeux fermés c'est
vrai que c'est le seul moment où on voit
pas où on est quand on a plus de lumière
et plus de points de repère non en fait
on essayé de communiquer comme ça être
se donner des rendez vous réguliers mais
en fait c'étaient des rendez vous
manqués puisque on a essayé de savoir si
on pensait la même chose laissez jamais
arrivé ouais alors pour échapper à cette
prison vous décidé d'écrire ce livre
et puis bientôt votre père est victime
dans l'infarctus alors vous demander à
être transféré à marseille aux baumettes
finalement vous vous retrouvez à la
prison de luynes à près
d'aix-en-provence et là l'isolément et
terrible cirque est même plus de
fenêtres à ce moment-là de fuyants plein
de monde de l'été la 40e' fait 40 à 50
dans les cellules c'est des trucs qui
font 9 mètres carrés mais séparément
mois un verre je suis pas en train de
tout les gens qui sont dans les prisons
dans ces conditions-là souffre pareil et
le solaire apparent c'est celui qui
passe sous la porte ouais et donc qu'on
est jugé pas inventé tout le monde on
est dans cet état on est appelés avant
de partir en train de respirer sous la
porte puisqu'il n'y a pas de fenêtre
qu'on a le lit c'est un truc en béton
qui est scellée dans le c'est vachement
dur par rapport aux phocéens s'étaient
mais là vous dites là vous dites quand
même j'ai sérieuses envies de suicide
quand même à vous mais c'est
pratiquement tout le temps dans les
débuts comme ça c'est d'ailleurs
incroyable une lutte entre votre
conscience qui lui veut absolument
cesser de vous battre et votre
inconscient qui vous donne l'énergie
pour le faire et vous remarquerez que
tous les suicides dans les prisons sont
d'abord interviennent très vite à peine
dans les premières semaines et pas
souvent sur des condamnés de longues
peines autrement dit ça n'a rien à voir
avec la projection d'une vie sans espoir
alors à vous raconter dans ce bouquin
toute votre vie quoi la faire rêver à le
crédit lyonnais van der mast d'alou
qu'enfin tout toutes vos affaires et
puis votre engagement politique et vous
dites que en fait mon engagement
politique a sonné le glas de mon bonheur
c'est à dire que jusque là tout vous
réussit c'est un moment vous raconterez
mitterrand qui voulaient pied à l'étrier
et en 92 kambere gauvois vous propose
d'être ministre de la ville en fait vous
ne savez pas mais c'est très content
vous à ce moment là je suis je saute sur
mon lit je suis heureux comme un enfant
parce que c'était venu d'où je venais je
venais du même endroit de bérégovoy la
rnt ça qui était symboliquement
intéressant à l'époque il existe encore
des ministres qui étaient des ministres
de famille d'ouvriers ça existe depuis
maintenant et c'est dommage et bérégovoy
qui m'appellent pour être ministre ça a
été pour moi un choc énorme au point
j'ai accepté tout balancer d'arrêter
toutes les affaires sans essayé de
calculer si c'était un dieu nous parle à
tout le monde vous prendre pour un gros
malin enfin c'est quand même un peu
excusez moi je suis malin non mais vous
êtes très malin mais enfin tout
abandonner c'est à dire abandonner toute
chose à faire est arrivé un job de
ministre à non non c'est pas pour un job
de ministre attendait ça faisait cinq
ans que j'étais député j'ai été député
européen depuis trois ans et je mesurais
malgré tous les bonheurs que j'avais pu
rencontrer dans les eaux de vie que ce
soit footballeur que ce soit dans le
ciné max de 20 ans j'avais mesurer que
c'était c'était gratifiant c'était
c'était vraiment l'activité humaine qui
me correspondait le mieux j'en avais une
envie folle alors qu' à aucun moment
j'ai les projets que ça reste qu est-ce
que c'est pas manqué de cynisme à ce
moment là vous auriez dû vous dire bon
bérégovoy et me propose et ministre vais
quand même pas mettre tous mes oeufs
dans le même panier parce que c'est ce
que vous avez fait finalement oui mais
parce que la banque était ma banque
depuis 17 ans ils étaient mes associés
et administrateur dans mon conseil
d'administration c'étaient des amis des
bains qui passent leurs vacances avec
moi alors j'explique à nos amis
téléspectateurs vous venez de racheter
adidas est devenu ministre vous devez
vous en séparer parce qu'effectivement
il va y avoir des licenciements chez
adidas 5 6000 licenciements à prévoir
quand on est ministre de la ville ces
mauvaises gens dont vous vous séparez
d'adidas toutes les affaires voilà vous
donner un mandat de vente au crédit
lyonnais et je voudrais dire est très
très important bairi qu'on le vise
aujourd'hui il s'agit pas du crédit
lyonnais d'aujourd'hui c'est bien mais
je pense que c'est important qu'on le
sache s'agit de l'ancien craindrait et à
ce moment là le crédit lyonnais se
revend à lui même adidas que je sache
pas le prix c'est incroyable dire qu'ils
revendent en fait à des sociétés
offshore qui leur appartiennent et
ensuite seulement ils le rendent à
robert louis-dreyfus vallée du doubs
voilà comment ça s'est passé exactement
donc vous comment avez vous su cette
histoire c'est comment avoir reçu
quelques lyonnais ont lieu devant
directement à robert louis dreyfus avait
vendu d'abord les sociétés offshore et
un coup de chance incroyable j'avais une
juge d'instruction qui était acharnée
contre moi comme elle l'a été d'ailleurs
à chaque fois qu'elle avait une cible
c'est madame joly qui est par ailleurs
une femme peu importe à la sellette
j'étais pas son pote et donc elle
cherchait par tous les moyens comment
est-ce qu'il n'a pas un compte à
l'étranger commencent à peu elle a fait
des perquisitions partout dans tous les
lieux où je risquais d'avoir une prime
concernant et aux lieux aux lyonnais à
l'as pris tous mes comptes les gestion
des comptes les comptes rendus de mes
comptes et aux prenantes où elle a pris
les bordereaux qu'étaient les actes de
portage des sociétés offshore est
d'accord c'est à dire on découvre la
secoue québec sociétés qui ont acheté
c'était en fait des sociétés qui
faisaient portage c'est elle qui ta peau
et la vie pendant des mois qui a été
gagné 167 millions d'euros la vie est la
passion et je vais vous dire pourquoi la
france sur la 3g un petit mot à lui dire
justement maintenant que le jugement est
rendu c'est qu'à l'époque on lui a dit
mais madame vous rendez compte que ça
serait peut-être intéressant maintenant
qu'on sait au moins qu'est ce qu'est
devenu cet argent puisqu'il est parti en
offshore elle m'a dit je suis pas saisit
de la sphère oui c'est à dire que à la
fais chier b dumas pendant des plombes
pour savoir qui lui avait jeté ses
pompages de la famile balle mais elle a
jamais voulu savoir qui avait sorti
l'argent des offshore qui se trouvait au
berner bien aller là ce soir
alors effectivement
à partir de là il yal'affaire des
comptes de l'om la fraude fiscale sur le
phocéa enfin pour vous c'est la bérézina
marionnettes jusqu'à jusqu'à 80 13
compris et algériens pas une
condamnation et après 94 c'est voler
tout je fais des faux tableaux je fais
je fais des déménagements des
détournements d'actifs d escroquerie
abus de confiance une banqueroute enfin
un an et demi ouais ils m'ont fait un
palmarès unique en france vous êtes
devenu l'homme à abattre parce que
effectivement vous êtes devenus
ministres et votre carrière politique
semblait s'ouvrir sous de bons auspices
ils ont eu peur que vous présentiez au
aux élections c'était plus simple c'est
que en france en politique pour mourir
il faut être condamnée par les deux
côtés ouais si vous êtes d'un côté
l'autre vous protège comme ils se
tiennent un peu il n'y a pas de risque
là j'étais j'ai pas eu de chance parce
que je venais de faut bien le dire
éliminer rocard 1/2 politique alors
qu'il était aux européennes nous aviez
fait 12,5 est lui très 5,1 s'était même
+12 9 et 13 4 ans ferme et la liste
socialiste c'était vraiment que des gens
formidables yahvé kouchner rien et
langues il y avait un requin en fait
c'était toute la banque quoi donc ils se
sont dit mais ce mec qui vient tout seul
nous faire pratiquement de ce corps il
faut pas qu'ils nous fassent paillot
présidentielle avec jose pas et la
droite voulait garder marseille
ou blanc était candidat donc la droite
voulait m'éliminer pour pas je sois
maire de marseille et la gauche pour pas
que je fasse chier j'ose pas hélas comme
tu as les deux c'est à dire pile tu as
perdu face tu as perdu faut que la la la
ouais pièce elle tombe sur la tranche et
c'est pas facile en d'autres temps en
d'autres temps je pense que le problème
aurait été réglé d'une manière
différente je suis même certain il vous
aurait mis une balle dans la peau vous
pensez part je pense que la plaint qu'on
finit éliminés dans des conditions plus
dramatique que la mienne dans ces ados
robert boulin un donc doigt c'est comme
ça personne n'a obligé de le faire j'ai
commis l'imprudence de le faire et voilà
on m'y reprendra plus alors aujourd'hui
vous êtes acteur un vous jouez dans
commissaire valence sur tf1 que marrant
c'est très sympa challenge bien en plus
vont la voir à quoi ça ressemble magnéto
serge
10h balance s'est tournée cette semaine
et pas mal hein tu allumes chez les
cascades lui-même c'est-à-dire une heure
et demie comme ça et qu'on sent
nettoyage très bien de dialogue quel âge
vous avez 60 c'est bien
mais bien la tâche
arrivé à il est coriace le tpir monte
cristo il est coriace oui alors donc ça
acteurs on a vu le business je vais
revenir dans les affaires non-vie niveau
là à mon réseau roue de tracteur ah bon
je fais du théâtre tous les ans à paris
l'année d'après en province je fais 4 5
valence par an je suis vachement heureux
mais c'est si j'ai découvert une
activité avec le théâtre qui est unique
ouais moi je vous ai vu sur scène c'est
chiant mais j'ai pu croire un beau
[ __ ] et ça fait drôle d'être heureux
autant que s'abat alors c'est ça il fait
ça paraît que nous un alors le business
non le sport et les revenir dans le
sport oui parce que ça c'est un truc
l'om je reprenais om nom lorraine marche
bien vous êtes sur lci dans onze matches
mais ça c'est marrant j'ai brassé des
postes dit que vous n'êtes pas là
l'émission à la vous les avez accroché
une drogue dure bah ouais je dis que
vous n'êtes pas dans l'émission elle
aussi c'étaient des journalistes assez
compétent matraque tout le monde et qui
casse tout le monde les joueurs les
clubs les dirigeants et tout est là moi
je suis arrivé pour les casser eu un peu
pour leur dire attendez vous dit des
conneries et tout donc les gens se
marrent évidemment comment ça va à
bernard et pascal praud très bien vous
n'avez pas mis un pain aujourd'hui mais
on va très bien depuis la cicatrise et
de fait vous êtes réconcilier avec
pascal praud oui à bord n'a jamais été
fâché à pince pas méchant mais tu vois
passat un bourre-pif entre amis enfin
franchement y'a pas de quoi faire si
c'est vrai bernard que vous allez
reprendre le red star pour faire une
deuxième équipe parisien c'est ce que
j'aimerais faire à sa serait bien parce
que c'est une vraie équipe de banlieue
elle et elle a une histoire
extraordinaire à saint-ouen par
conséquent pas loin du stade de france
le jour on sera en première division
mais enfin ça y'a rien de fait mais moi
j'aimerais travailler avec eux voilà ça
serait bien mais pas forcément en étant
le t1 et la politique alors non je
regarde je reviens non non non non
sérieusement sérieusement je vais
revenir chez mes potes radicaux parce
que c'est vraiment des gens qui m'ont
soutenu tout le temps mais pour faire
comme chacun de ceux qui s'intéressent à
la politique sans être élu sa veste un
pays en france où je le faisais avant
avant je faisais toutes les émissions
politiques j'étais pas élu quand je me
suis fait le pen je n'étais pas élu non
et j'étais invité pour parler avec lui
pas gentiment d'ailleurs est bon on est
troisième à sept mois donc on n'est pas
obligé d'être élu pour faire de la
politique à coeur non simplement les
clients les bons clients sont part à son
de son art ouais parce que votre femme
anna di toute façon s'il refait de la
politique j'ai du vorsent oui bah oui
elle a quand même beaucoup souffert oui
elle était très courageuse un canton en
canton relève le lin c'est une grossesse
comme ça ouais ouais je comprends vous
la trouviez pas en fait bah voila je
suis comme vous et mme alain un barrage
et il a trouvé normes il a trouvé quand
même si désolée solide et courageuse
quand même un dominique là parce que
évident ouais
bon alors là maintenant on va passer
koren et encore quand même quelques
nuages noirs bernard on va les évoquer
vous avez des ennemis vous le savez le
cdr qui est l'organisme liquide acteurs
des actifs de l'ancien crédit lyonnais
lui veulent en cassation a le cdr c'est
à dire ils disent nos mamans nous on
n'accepte pas la décision du tribunal
donner à bernard tapie 147 millions
d'euros nous on venait en cassation il
dit ça fait neuf ans finalement on peut
essayer de gagner de trois ans de plus
d'accord en gros c'est la société de
défaisance du cahier ouais c'est ça la
elle a pris tous les actifs et comme son
nom l'indiqué ça doit être quelque chose
qu'à une vie extrêmement courte pris
puisque ça doit trancher les litiges ça
doit vendre nos actifs et vivre à l'abri
trancher les litiges vers un bruit ils
sont encore là ils dépensent par parents
des centaines de millions d'euros
d'avocats ah oui d'accord qu'ils sont
toujours les mêmes a ouais d'accord et
les avocats passent leur temps à
expliquer ce coup ci on va gagner un
corner sur
l'exécutive life ils ont pendant huit
ans expliqué qu'ils allaient gagner sa
croûte et 500 millions d'euros aux
français ouais et aujourd'hui c'est en
train de nous expliquer la en cassation
on va gagner ouais alors bon ils peuvent
durer encore deux mètres mais dans cet
organisme la ja votre ami charles de
courson il est maintenant lien c'est un
député un député ump de la marne je
crois il vous aime pas non et pourquoi
pas je dois pas être son genre
lui il a les fils du peuple c'est ça non
non je sais pas du tout je ne connais
pas bon il se trouvait là a mené un
combat qu'il poursuit avec toute sa
haine etc moi je lui rends pas je ne le
connais pas par contre ce qui est
inquiétant quand même concernant ce
personnage en gros pour que les gens
sachent un doctrinaire moraliste lui
veulent en cassation mais lui veut faire
la morale avant le procès souvenez vous
il y avait une grande émission sur je
sais plus si c'est la cie sous la iii on
appelle les émission d'investigation sur
le procès aucun avocat aucun et aucune
partie ni moi ni adidas avons accepté
d'aller à cette émission alors qu'on
était un mois du délibéré lui oui oui
faire ça le dérange pas d'aller fracassé
de parler d'un sujet alors que
normalement totalement interdite le tout
pour essayer de forcer la main on va
juste rats et puis là depuis que le
jugement mais il continue il commenté il
est incroyable parce que quand on dit
bernard tapie pourrait revenir en
politique ce qui apparemment n'est pas
le cas lui il est déjà prévu il vit mais
bernard tapie pour la présidentielle par
exemple il trouvera jamais 500
signatures waouh à la présidentielle
bernard tapie ne trouvera jamais 500
signatures riches il a dit par exemple
c'est que si on fait pas 5% obligé de
rembourser les frais de campagne qui
sont payés par le gouvernement il mais
si tapie ne fait pas 5%
qui va payer les frais de campagne et y
pense déjà violé à la présidentielle et
que vous n'aurez pas les 500 signatures
et que vous ne ferez pas 5% je crois
qu'il est digne d'être dans l'écurie de
bayrou en fait ces [ __ ] ça il est
dans l'écurie de bayrou et oui bah oui
autre problème par rapport à l'avenir
bernard tapie et la cena là bas avec
notre ami course on sait les affaires
pendant que c'est à dire la fraude
fiscale pour commencer alors vous on
vous dit voilà va falloir payer encore
vous dit attendez j'ai été déjà il est
génial j'ai été tellement sévèrement
jugés non mais ça ce sont toutes les
affaires pénales qui étaient suspendus
au résultat de la sphère civile par
conséquent maintenant que la sphère
civile est connu les magistrats ont
entre leurs mains les éléments
d'évaluation qui n'avaient pas je dois
dire que grâce à deux au parquet au
parquet général on a réussi à
interrompre un cycle infernal sans ça on
aurait pu rester encore cinq ans comme
sarin une question moi qui m'intéresse
c'est pendant toute cette période là
disons des dix dernières années pendant
que vous attendiez le procès en appel
finalement quels sont les gens qui vous
ont pas laissé tomber tous mes potes
genre
kouchner séguéla jacques lang le lait
borloo borloo bien sûr ouais je me suis
pas gouré sur mes copains
qui a publié ces messieurs
m
alors bon tapis comme vous êtes le roi
de la tchatche vous allez finir mes
phrases
je donne mes débuts comme donner un
train
en ce moment je sais pas ce que j'aimais
ça se présente pas mal
c'est bien un truc que je sais pas faire
c'est
faire semblant
la seule différence entre le théâtre et
la politique c'est quand on tue au
théâtre c'est pour faire rire
bravo
ce qui manque à chirac par rapport à
mitterrand c'est jacques séguéla le seul
truc que j'ai jamais pu m'offrir avec
l'argent c'est le crédit lyonnais
je me serai remboursé plus tôt
pas pouvoir est en général j'ai plus aux
femmes qui ont le goût du risque c'est
vrai au moins franchement maintenant je
peux te le dire les missions que je
faisais sur tf1 je regrette de l'avoir
arrêté
allez allez comme ça une bonne tête mais
montre en or je tiens à l'âge pour
pour t'apprendre que tu fais pas la
différence entre l'a6 et l'a7
avait des prêts des barrois en quoi on
en a chié la santé
pour nom mais il a été sympa avec moi
parce qu'un jour j'ai gardé ça et je
vais garder un on est on faisait les
missions sur canal
juste avant que j'y aille vie j'ai un
truc pour toi tu le regardes ça quand tu
seras parti pris d'une quinte rapproche
quand je sors je regarde ce que c'était
car du monopoly vous êtes libéré de
prison assez bien
la capitaine salvini cermex au micro en
direct à la télévision
thierry cette incroyable depuis la
dernière fois ce que tu as tu sens plus
heureux
mais il n'y a même pas de comparaison
c'est le soir qui fait ça ça égaye tous
deux sont un lieu de vraiment porte bien
le deuil je sens que ça y est voilà le
jour mais 60 ans je me suis dit tout
marche à et tout marche ah ouais t'as
besoin de viagra du cialis
et là dedans le banc fin et franchement
si tu avais été au ballon à ma place je
suis sûr que tu en es boîte est alors
été plus normal
ça aurait fait plus normal merde
le combat le plus dur que j'ai eu à
mener c'est une chanson de brassens qui
dit les gens n'aiment pas que l'on suive
pas le même chemin que ouais bah c'est
un peu ce contre cela que c'était dur et
mauvaise réputation voilà c'est ce
qu'ils veulent pas qu'on soit différent
quoi la série sont nombreux aujourd'hui
ce qui me rend le plus fier c'est
mes enfants les cadres c'est marrant
malgré tout ce que j'ai vécu je continue
à croire que
qu'il faut toujours y croire
des fois je me dis si seulement j'avais
pas
alors ça je me le dis jamais
jamais jamais pas une fois je me suis
dit ah si j'avais su mais c'est ce que
j'aime dans la vie j'ai pas de
rétroviseur mais par contre je garde
c'est ce qui fait que je garde jamais
demeuré souvenirs des gens qui m'ont
fait chier je promets à celui qui me
traitent encore dans à dix mètres un
passé ce sont des souvenirs d'un truc
chez moi j'aimerais que ce soit j'ai
fait une des écoles pour les jeunes qui
étaient sans boulot ouais et on à la
sortie près de 10000 sans rien demander
à personne et il y en a près de 10000
dans la nature ouais q rue
belle carrière grâce à mme parmi tous
les salopards qui m'ont trahi je
n'oublierai jamais
que mes potes n'étaient pas dans le lot
ouais
bah fait leur entrée à tanger eut
demandé ça
il ya quelques années tu t'es tu t'es
battu avec quelqu'un un peu comme avec
pascal praud il est là sa tombe est de
le voir vous très sympa je m'en fous tu
vas dû serrer la main ben ça dépend qui
sait michaël youn
j'ai deux gérants c'est l'appel moi je
tiens je t'apporte et parce que c'est
quoi l'histoire c'était
c'était sur 7 et sur skyrock mais assure
que bernard se souvient même pas au fait
tu dois peut-être même pas se souvenir
que c'est moi je vois que tu viens à
passe si mais si on regarde ça tu
reviens pas je veux toujours que si
bernard était invité pour parler de
l'excellent site internet de son fils
des ans
et il y avait un auditeur qui lui a posé
une question sur sur le match benfica
marseille à l'époque où il y avait eu la
main de vata tu étais sorti du match en
disant je me suis fait avoir une fois tu
recommences tu vois l'auditeur n'a pas
dit exactement la phrase que vous aviez
dit à l'époque voilà l'auditeur a dit
vous avez aimé maman comment faut faire
voilà et donc rien à voir avec ce que
gêné qu'alcon alors l'auditeur dit si
vous avez 10 à bernard bernard dit non
je n'ai pas dit ça le dire si ça non
également jeudi bon ok on va couper la
poire en deux bernard de toute façon que
vous l'ayez dit ou pas vous avez fait 8
mois de prison s'était même pas pour
rien c'est ça que je fais et c'est là
que vous êtes énervé un peu quoi c'était
un peu une phrase de petit con mais ça
marche c'est par ici
donc voilà rejette son casque on était
en différé bernard 715,6 dit quoi je
viens en ami on pose des questions à la
con comme ça il va dans le bureau du
directeur dit non je suis pas d'accord
comment ça se fait qu'on traite comme ça
et moi je vais le voir un petit peu
désolé je dis bon vous savez ce qu'on va
faire berner comme on n'est pas en
direct on va ré enregistrés à la fin et
c'est là que vous m'avez dit non on va
pas réagi jusqu'à la fin ce qu'on va
faire c'est que je vais te casser la
gueule
là et là bernard avec c'est très très
belle palucher ces très grosses paluches
bas mais une bonne petite claque dans la
gueule à une claque et moi je
viens c'est par ailleurs le il
accompagne bien le mouvement et à ce
moment là mon directeur d'antenne m'a
demandé de présenter mes excuses que
j'ai refusé de faire et défaire et de
fun était fâché non mais tu vois parfois
il ya des choses qui t'énerve parce que
le mec il peut te prendre en défaut
entre citant une de tes phrases il faut
que tu l'acceptent mais pas qui tu cite
une phrase que t'as pas dit oui mais
pourquoi pourquoi il claque à l'époque
je n'en sais pas ce que veut tu t'es pas
pris parce que tu devrais malin oui ces
jouets faire le malin tu avais envie de
te faire pousser et puis en plus je suis
pas sûre et la question tu l'avais pas
fait poser exprès non et voilà et c'est
là que vous avez tort parce qu'il y en a
des mecs qui font ça tue 5 le canard il
faut pas s'arrêter au passé des textos
en bas des écrans rendent pas tu vois ça
existe les mains qui font des phrases
qui existe pas ou qui reçoivent des sms
qu'ils inventent jamais une façon
un masque à l'époque à l'époque pour
comprendre que jamais un sport il y
avait un sport casser du tapis voilà
c'est que les mecs c'est à celui qui
arrive est le mieux morrell alors il n'y
en a pas beaucoup mais c'est vrai qu'il
ya une analyse sur toi choix des bons
gars comme je te dire allez ça va les
mecs lorsque tu vas faire tu vas dire
son livre ah oui là d'appel
bien entendu librement
mesdames messieurs
tu vois mon petit berckois basile boli
soir oui 93 bon tu as très bien ces
primes a quitté ses deux manches à zéro
c'est fait c'est vrai et il a toujours
eu des noirs qu'on ne sait vraiment mais
laisse tomber c'est toi bernard j'ai
toujours eu des blagues comme cuisiner
c'est horrible où tu étais succès qua
non mais attends c'est un scoop ça
devrait se voir je ne veux pas la mort
mais si son pote qui était chez moi un
assist le sénégal et la wii était pas
mal dans sa tête elle pâtit si c'est
bien tu risques et avait pâti site avec
wat avec combien de domestique à
l'époque
away simple pâtissier cuisinier ma femme
faisait le ménage un jardin
12 18 à 18 à 18 mais c'était que sur le
bateau
mon p'tit bal du loup
quand on te voit les mamans bébés
c'était un c'était quand
tu as vu la pierre j'ai regardé la rose
est une très belle jambe mais bon et je
vais très bien aussi j'étais franchement
c'est pas pour dire mais les gens ils y
vont pour toi ils vont aussi beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup pour elle quand elle
en recul en moi je sais que même moi ça
c'est
l'attaqué d'ailleurs
petit bateau
mettez vous à ma place tous les soirs
non je pourrais dire c'est un jour une
cavalcade parce qu'un jour je n'ai vu
faire rez-de-chaussée premier étage rez
de chaussée en moins de 7 secondes
l'écart
avec un tout petit truc très très bas et
à bercy ni prendre sous elle est
allongée il est sur le point d'achever
sur la semaine pour que l'autre 10
entrées
ma culotte roptin elle avait tracé
900 personnes qui après 10 heures on l'a
vu à l'essai vrai brûlant va de soi
qu'un bateau
va vous auriez refusé du monde pendant
des spéciales a pas voulu à l'armement
moi j'ai vu la pièce sur les palois de
sharon stone ou
bien
tout simplement battant à mort que c'est
un compliment c'est que vous reprenez la
phrase je veux j'ai j'ai mon petit bonne
foi voilà une rentrée en personne soit
appelée sort anglais si norman et elle
est connue
c'est le business card pour la baisse
sur des coûts en euros et en dollars
blasé de l'asile tu prenais tout nous en
dollars mais c'est fini à 6 ans blake
et on cherche un mec
c'est cher mais comme base ils n'ont pas
cher battant
20-13 munich mais il prend hyper chic
chez moi il a pris dix fois ce qu'il
avait fait à auxerre patty fois rien tu
veux je te dis les chiffres
d'affaires sont sévères de l'époque
parce que c'est surtout un sens guy roux
be wild pas de payer des risques obama
bombay est beaucoup dire oui respecter
les internationaux les qui vous allez
mieux que les nazis franchement tapie a
été plus généreux les japonais c'est
rita baus heures passent et moins
qu'avec moi même avec les as poney
express de vente
je raconte répète une anecdote sais pas
si tu oses le reconnaître
parce que j'avais des manières de
management qui avait rien à voir l'ex
président ça c'est vrai il ya une chose
qui est totalement déconseillé
et pour cause c'est qu'avant un grand
événement le la veille d'une finale par
exemple c'est de laisser les macaques et
lombez pour faire les comptes ça c'est
un truc dabrowski qui perd de l'énergie
il a de la concentration derrière toi tu
poses pas baiser avant les émissions et
avant les marées non moi je pense tout
le contraire mais je suis le seul et un
jour on allait à brest puis on faisait
la finale de la coupe de france à paris
contre monaco grosse finale et le et on
retournait pas à marseille parce qu'on
avait encore un truc à faire
où je mets des militaires dans les
couloirs parce que tous aient compris
dont se rendent pas compte de toutes les
équipes quand elles viennent la veille à
paris les mecs la nuit ils se cassent
ils vont faire les coins aucun diesel
comme ils sont trop cons pour s'en
rendre compte de ça dont qui disent
attention demain et tous les mecs qui
vont faire pour moi je leur ai dit et on
va pas faire les cons à paris alors
londres et vous avez pas besoin de les
faire ch amène le matos cris 6 1 et les
mecs comment le président souhaiterait
attend gokalp mon entraîneur qui à côté
mais l'emploi non présidence vous pouvez
pas faire une chose pareille on
rencontre monaco en finale demain mais
c'est pas possible ça puis d'accord ce
produit et on lui dit tranxène
plat la purée ya une purée est bien trop
plein la purée ce gothel s'il prend la
pire et elle me le risque où s'ébat ça
et moi je préviens et je prévois plein
de matos pour qu'ils soient tous servis
dans chacun dans sa chambre tu en penses
tu ces espèces de montréal tous dans une
fiole il dans une chambre sais pas si tu
vois une champ le novotel
sur les 11 14 joueurs et là je crois 2,3
seulement dom'asile wii 2 3 joueurs dont
basic ont pas voulu
heureusement et après tout ça était plus
grand parc le lendemain n'écrasez monaco
ces mecs là ils ont besoin pour être
totalement au de l'heureux leur forme
ils ont besoin de faire secret tu es
tous leurs éléments naturels que sont la
cortisone l'adrénaline tester la version
qu'ils sont dans leur propre corps
c'était ça pour ça tu as des gens qui
ont besoin au contraire qui se met la
tête ailleurs pas besoin de les divertir
tu as besoin de changer les idées parce
que sinon ils se mettre dans le rouge
parce qu'ils font le match 3 x 20 fr ils
dorment pas la nuit sont très angoissés
et s'étend à d'autres au contraire il
faut les mettre dedans parce qu'ils
n'arrivent pas à se concentrer n'a pas
déclenché les processus de mobilisation
et de sa dépendent pas du tout être bien
savoir dans ce sens lorsque bernard avec
l'adrénaline soit a besoin qu'on l'aide
à la secrétaire soit tu l'as sécrète toi
même
qu'est-ce qu'est ce qui se passe l'om là
il paraît que depuis quatre mois c'est
qu'est-ce qui se passe bah oui ce
boucher ne serait pas selon tapis de se
boucher ne serait pas la route est
selon moi
il ya une grande différence ces deux
métiers différents que de raconter ce
que font les autres et de faire c'est
pas le même boulot or bush est un mec
qui toute sa vie a raconté ce que nous
faisons et ce que plutôt mal d'ailleurs
non mais
tu as love s'était pas c'était pas vide
il a fait ce qu'on aimerait surtout à
boucher non mais c'est parce qu'il a
fait plus mal sûr de toi et moi je parle
du quotidien il n'était pas ce n'est pas
drôle journaliste au nouvel obs n'était
pas une plume je dire ce n'est pas toi
c'est pas daniel s'était pas tout ça
c'était rien vu c'est une piste dans
bond et mais quand même il a fait toute
sa vie pour raconter
il a fait un livre sur toi 3 combien
marché bien marché ouais c'est fait du
pognon alors qu'ils étaient bien dont le
dernier qui était pas sur moi c'était
comment faire du fric sans rien savoir
et c'est bien parce que il a appliqué la
méthode qui la met un a lieu
il prend 100 mille euros par mois net en
sachant toujours rien son nom
et bronze 100 euros par mois alors qu'il
sait rien et qu'il est en train de mener
le danseur
il y avait des mecs qui sont sur le
terrain il y avait un tandem boucher et
père un père lt l'entraîneur est
différent les pertes il sait il a été
limogé et élimine joué par boucher avec
qui il était complètement copains et
tout ça et il est vrai qu'au départ tout
le monde a pensé que c'était une bonne
solution de bonne formule duo tous
beaucoup saccomano
à ça tout le monde pensait que l'om
allait repartir puis c'est vrai qu'ils
achètent pas mal bon le recrutement ils
se sont admis pente et ça ça a été leur
problème les trois quatre premières
journées de championnat tout est le
premier à dire c'était génial z
champions dont je leur dis pas
que j'ai touché à tout moment temps mort
moi il ya un truc c'est vrai que on
refait le match c'est mon émission à un
formidable parce que je n'ai pas très
bien ou
alors que je pensais l'avoir moi c'est
extra c'est un papier recevoir un livre
de chez gallimard nrf jeter dans la
collection des mecs de chercheurs sur
faute sur le sport les hommes est toute
simple dans la collection les chercheurs
ouais et le l'auteur
premier chapitre s'appelle on refait le
match à huy et sur trois pages il
raconte notre histoire un peu et ils
disent ces types là qui se réunissent
autour d'une table raconte des trucs
dise la vérité est apte à médéa vérité
n'ont pas la langue de bois en tout cas
tapie bernard alors que les joueurs les
dirigeants
vous nous racontez habituellement que
des trucs demande à base quand il était
joueur ça va bien bas ça va très bien
même s'il était emmerder comme tout est
le problème c'est que c'est la langue
non langue de bois le fond dans le sable
ils savent qu'il ya des choses qui
peuvent pas dire il se la raconte un peu
merger en maginot cela raconte ce qui va
être écrit dans l'équipe le lendemain
les gens vont le savoir alors suite
expliqué
vas-y vas-y ses journalistes et des
copains et gêne ça fait il m'a suivi
depuis auxerre jusqu'à marseille etc
c'est des copains ils savent qu'ils
doivent prendre des infos avec nous
évidemment est donc ils peuvent pas dire
certains trucs ce qu'ils font là c'est
gentil lorsque tu dis c'est qu'en fait
ils donnent l'impression de dire la
vérité semble avérée le sable avait
accusé de connivence
le challenge account de pons comblant
métier c'est ses journalistes ouais non
les journalistes à partir du moment où
ils sont près des décideurs du foot ils
pensent qu'ils sont décideurs mais
attends attends a press gène j tu étais
aussi important dans ton dans son métier
auprès des joueurs de l'équipe de france
on était très lié parce qu'on voulait
parler avec toi moi mais c'est plus
qu'un bon je sais pas mais à mon époque
quand au louis c'est tout le monde quand
tu venais tettey labit voilà mais on te
disait certains et certaines choses en
off que tu
tu racontes est bien mais tu allais pas
jusqu'au bout c'est ce qu'ils font et
c'est ce qu'ils font ils vont pas au
bout de ce qu'ils pensaient ils savent
ça va un peu plus loin
par ces types parce que vient de dire
basile boli sont attendus mardi je veux
pas je parle moi pas c'est vrai ça
signale à 6,26 sida alors maintenant
c'est une émission c'est quoi les
missions
exceptionnelles par l'animateur puis par
le casting parce que tu as le faux blast
à le faux-cul talent gentil talent mais
chantal vagin ne peut donc un donc celui
qui veut voir
celui qui cherche pas à comprendre ce
que c'est le football la réalité
sportive de ce qui se passait nous
menace voilà tu as regardé ça tu te
régales voilà le reste il y en a deux
maximum qui savent à peu près ce que
c'est alors scd ringard ils comprennent
rien mais rien non j'entends des trucs
mais c'est à mourir de rire
c'est ridicule
journalistes on lui demande deux choses
1 c'est de raconter les événements tels
qu'ils se sont passés pas tel qu'il
aurait envie que ça se soit passé ce qui
n'est pas le cas du journal sportif et
deuxièmement ils essayent quand même
d'être le plus objectif possible même si
par ailleurs il a ses propres sentiments
il essaie de parler faire transparaître
le football c'est pas le cas talent mais
qu un fana de lyon tu as eu la finlande
paris saint-germain fayyad voilà donc
c'est ça qui les rend à la fois mais
formidablement jean réfute complètement
tout ce que tu as
honte a fait un dîner vieux port
d'alger pas vieux cochon vieux port à
rejeter bouger en escabèche
bouillabaisse de morue fraîche ou sablé
au magic en vie dure de fenouillet glace
de poivron rouge c'est sympa c'est c'est
ce qu'on mange ligne martin c'est ce
qu'on mange sur le bateau c'est
exactement cgc c'est ça tu en avais mec
qui emmenaient leurs équipes sur le
bateau venant bernard ya un truc en 15
parties là tu l'as vu le bouquin à
deux rigolos et perez là sur le psg tu
l'as vu toi le psg l'om une rivalité
cervoise la théorie des mecs si elle
arrive alors qu'en tapis diriger l'om il
était il était en position de monopole
donc pour que ce soit intéressant il
avait besoin de se créer un club
concurrent de toutes pièces pour faire
exister un peu le marché et il a pris le
psg denisot et ils ont monté en fait une
rivalité psg web comme il a tout appris
à denise au passage ses beats je veux
dire artificiel siva la vérité c'est que
tu avais j'étais pas lui connaît toute
la vérité donc je la vivais a devant lui
la vérité c'est que c'est vrai que le
niveau général du football français
j'arrive je voudrais quand même te
rappeler s'était jamais un club à part
depuis la mort de sa dtn je parle
c'était il ya plus un club jamais quand
il y en a car et leur huitième de finale
de coupe d'europe aux vielles bon et je
te signale que les années 88 89 90 91
c'était demi finales quart de finale
demi-finale deux finales bon on a changé
la nature pourquoi parce que c'est vrai
que c'est que te delà du niveau de la
concurrence qu'est ce que tu fais le
niveau du leader
si un mec est classé ultra forts en
tennis et qui joue qu'avec des ringards
docile et n'étaient pas là ringardos qui
deviennent bons c'est le bon qui
deviendrait donc j'ai fait le plus
possible la promotion auprès d'eux mais
comme aulas caprion aulas c'est moi qui
les fais rentrer dans lyon c'est vrai
que c'est moi qui ai convaincu canal de
mettre de l'argent dans le psg de
reprendre le pg et ils ont bien fait de
le faire bon tout ça pourquoi parce que
ça faisait b à bordeaux caen port à qui
était très très bon et qui était à
monaco ça faisait au la sq était à lyon
ça faisait mois que sa manière ce camp
mais tu n'as fait avec le psg mais avec
tous les autres clubs c'est bien sûr
le foot c'était qu'on voit dans les faux
pas qu'est ce qui s'est passé entre eux
dreyfus est bouché samand sûrement pas
pour elle d'abord à la décharge de
boucher fois il a fait c'est aussi à moi
j'y suis allé une saison là pour voir ça
se passait et j'ai parfaitement compris
le problème le problème c'est qu'il faut
que ce soit dreyfus qui se passe car
c'est une fausse solution et en plus
c'est la fin du club parce que il aura
mis tellement d'argent les 1600
généralement plus que soit on est à plus
d'un milliard est cela dit c'est le
poteau qui m'a pris dans la glace donc
c'est pas grave
c'est quand une amie quand il a mis six
sont minimales des 13 milliards adidas
il peut en dépensant famille 600
millions a dit lamy dix fois plus que
moi bruit à l'époque j'aurais mis 50
très
lent ce qui est très grave si tu veux
c'est que maintenant un mec cas de
l'argent pour rien au monde il mettra
dans l'om parce que il aura eu le
sentiment quand même ça sert à rien les
mecs qui se succèdent sont pas des
mauvais ni les entraîneurs ni les
dirigeants mais j'y suis allé une fois
pour voir comment c'était c'est un mec
dramatique
le portier du stade appel il prend
téléphone il le voit il lui faut changer
un truc qui change les trucs la bonzesse
qui fait les maillots du c'est hot
maloya lavables qu'est-ce-qui fois et
madame r atteint de personnes c'est faux
de dire qu'il ya un qui dirige non tout
le monde dans un club c'est pas tout le
monde
mais il faut un taulier cas l'autorité
absolue elle ne serait ce que pour
protéger son son entraîneur mois le
troisième je l'attends je mets un jeune
entraîneur écoute bien c'est vraiment
quelque chose de très important je pense
que évidemment basile lui sûr mais même
aux gènes doit se rappeler de ça un
jeune entraîneur parce que je me suis
pas content de ben brahim saha bordel
beckenbauer il est le meilleur du monde
important mais il est maire du monde
avec des allemands ouais et quand je le
vois diriger mon équipe je deviens fou
il me met basile boli arrière droit il
met amoros libéraux on va aussi me
souviens de ça je crains pas et qui
avait les couilles de virer le champion
du monde au bout de deux mois si c'est
pas moi y'a personne qui aurait osé moi
j'ai rien à [ __ ] beckenbauer d'or et
je prends le l'entraîneur de 3e division
et que lequel on est champions et coupe
de france la même année qu'est
sérieux bernard vraiment sérieusement
sur regrette le ballon ces deux avec les
activités la chose qui manque le plus à
l
[Musique]
intrigue à tauriac un truc avec le
pouvoir de séduction que tu as qui a
fini par fonctionner avec moi et comment
ça se fait que tu aies pas eu plus de
conquêtes féminines
je pense que je vais
deux fois je plais planches on s en
fout mais c'est vrai qu'il a une
ambition révélant les jurés mais les
femmes
sam sont au bord en pâmoison
comment ça se fait avec le pouvoir de
ses choix lui bon à un moment tu les a
tous tordu l'atelier et comment avec les
gonzesses tu as eu quoi que la première
faille plus pas parce que c'est elle qui
le fait nana beaucoup doute
énormément jusqu'à j'ai fait trente ans
j'ai fait n'importe quoi avait jusqu'à
demain
bernard c'est bizarre quand même j'ai
jamais dit contrat moi qui l'aï dit
on sait jamais dit c'est pour la vie est
en effet l'un pour l'oeil pour tout le
temps au contraire on a toujours eu le
sentiment tout le temps que ça allait
pas de loi c'est drôle j'ai tu vois il
ya des couples qui se sont dits qu'ils
s'installent et qui ce qui se promettent
de bonne foie rein une qui se projette
plutôt km qui se projette vraiment qu'on
dit c'est la femme de ma vie on dit
plutôt c'est la femme de ma mort c'est à
dire c'est celle qui ira jusqu'à ma mort
bon
nous on sait jamais dit ça parce que ça
peut vraiment nous arriver à l'un et à
l'autre de demain elle est plus jeune
que toi oui à laquelle pas beaucoup à
l'eau sept ans de moins que moi non mais
attends elle donc le décidons et demi
alors ça vient un j'ai fait vraiment
beaucoup beaucoup de conneries beaucoup
et en partie les dernières sous ses yeux
parce qu'elle est elle bossait dans une
filiale d'une mes boîtes art et on s'est
connus par hasard incroyable
j'avais besoin de faire une opération à
genève entièrement langue anglaise
mascate et à moi était malade j'ai donc
été chercher à côté quelqu'un qui
parlait couramment l'anglais et elle
était sapé toujours chignon jupe au
dessous des genoux enfin vraiment le
contraire de l'exubérance au point que
jamais j'avais jamais percuter avec
cette nana et à l'époque mon scooter
plus concrètement et c'est au cours de
ce week-end là
toute ma vie je me rappellerai y avait
un d'un cocktail le soir à la fin du
contrat et j'avais travaillé avec elle
trois jours et et 3,2 minuit à traduire
les trucs plus vraiment sans la regarder
vraiment en la voyant 5 00h tu l'as bien
sinon parce qu'on a fini à
et le soir le dernier soir je suis dans
le hall de l'intercontinental j'attends
et je vois une nana décembre
f au fur et à mesure qu'elles approchent
je reconnais
elle avait lâché les cheveux lamy un
truc est tous là j'ai explosé en vol
mais je suis triste parce que j'aime
beaucoup bernard tapie comme comédien
que je l'avais beaucoup peiné dans le
dans le film de lelouch que je l'avais
également beaucoup aimé dans vol
au-dessus d'un nid de coucou mais je
trouve qu'il manque d'ambition c'est à
dire que je crois que c'est un véritable
comédien et lui même ne se prend pas
assez au sérieux et il ne fait pas le
métier d'acteur il n'essaie pas de jouer
un rôle on fait le bateleur non c'est un
complice non parce que moi j'aimerais un
vrai rôle j'aimerais le voir dans le
faiseur de balzac par exemple où il
serait absolument prodigieux dans les
affaires sont les affaires il ya des
rôles extraordinaire poursuit je trouve
qu'ils se contentent de peu et notamment
ma ce que j'aime passer c'est ce que je
regrette c'est le jeu vous avec le
public justement sur votre personne en
disant regardez je suis le personnage
dans ce formidable ça j'aime pas ça
quand ils arrivent en disant dans le
mensonge c'est quelque chose qui fait
qu'on va être en jésus parce que je vois
c'est là que jamais parce que c'est un
véritable acteur tapis et que là je vois
mais non pas un tapis mais je vois nanar
d'aider des guignols d'abord un mois je
suis de ceux qui
comprend complètement
les critiques
de ce que l'on fait dès lors que dans
certains métiers exposés qui est fait
pour séduire ou et que chaque avis
compte il ya personne qui a raison et
personnes 14 c'est comme la bouffe y en
a qui aiment ça d'autres pas donc moi
j'ai jamais je suis jamais vexé de tout
ce qu'on peut dire de moi dès lors qu'il
s'agit de ça j'étais vexé quand on
disait des choses fausses dans des
métiers où il n'y a pas la place pour
pour l'interprétation après ta tion ses
défaites bon donc maintenant j'explique
pourquoi cette première partie est comme
ça elle est écrite
de cette manière là c'est à dire que
c'est un acteur qui parle aux gens donc
moi j'ai dit à jean luc je veux bien à
jouer mais quand je parlerai aux gens je
veux leur part devant le rideau baissé
je veux leur parler c'est à dire je veux
que la lumière soit allumée et je veux
donc leur parler ça c'est le premier
point le deuxième point c'est qu'avant
d'arriver à la 2e partie
moi je suis vraiment maintenant dans la
tête je suis un acteur je vous assure
qu'en vous voyez donc un trait toujours
été un acte non non mais non mais quand
je suis dans valence avait reçu un
vecteur six mois dans ma tête chez un
acteur pour les gens je suis pas encore
un acteur et j'ai le temps utile à les
mettre dans la crédibilité
bernard tapie à la fiche du faiseur ou
autre chose je peux vous dire que ça
fait salle comble mais que ce soit en
janvier ou en juin parce que vous
représentez c'est vrai un phénomène
médiatique mais on appelle un péché de
faire mais on a fait le plein ouais vol
s'était alors vol c'est ambitieux
c'était beaucoup plus ambitieuse en
messieurs et que franchement et c'est là
mais je suis content
derrière nicholson fallait faire
très réussi mais timo bernhard ce qui
veut dire c'est pas c'est pas méchant il
dit
la prochaine fois fait un truc plus
ambitieux tu peux te permettre enfin
c'est ce que je veux dire tu peux te
permettre de faire un truc qui semble
réellement et ce n'est pas de la
flagornerie tout je trouve que c'est
bien seulement d'acteurs réels mais
cette pièce là jeudi a pas d'autre moyen
de la jouer parce que c'est en question
si tu peux être que vous avez donné que
vous avez à faire une pièce qui vous
voit faire ce qu'il faut faire dans
cette poule a fait avec oman et mouiller
sa chemise quand tu fermes en liga et
mouiller je dédie à la fin si tu ne fais
pas une à sabrina tu mouilles d'ashley
smith
il serait que je voulais absolument rire
article j'avais une envie de ça
vaut le tunnel coucou gelé fini je les
jouais 400 x 400 fois les gens ont
pleuré toute la salle j'ai fait 400
standing-ovation ce que j'ai pas fait
une seule fois dans cette pièce là on
était 16 ça finissait dans une
dramaturgie incroyable vous saurez plus
être d'un ridicule sans nom dès lors que
tu joues un mec qui lobotomise et si
j'avais fait ce que je fais dans la
deuxième partie dont celle à honoraires
libres
là c'était lobotomisés ge était
silencieux je bougeais pas un cil et les
gens pleuraient maintenant numéro un je
voulais faire rire car j'avais envie de
rire j'ai été privé de rire pendant pas
mal de temps si tu vois ce que je veux
dire et j'avais envie de rire être fermé
deuxièmement j'avais envie de donner un
peu de bonheur est là j'avais envie de
leur donner et je suis heureux de leur
donner vous n'imaginez pas à quel point
c'est la banane les gens sortent de là
ils sont heureux donc tu vois ça c'est
le point le point 2 je suis pas d'accord
c'est une pièce qui veut peut-être rien
dire au sens où elle fait pas appel à
l'intelligence profonde mais elles s'y
sont ceux-là qui sont le raisin sur la
rente sur la nam sur l'homme sur son
évolution en tant que pièce de boulevard
y en a quand même des des milliers
écrire sur ce thème est le dernier poids
le dernier point je veux faire un one
man show oui et ce one man show je les
écris il s'appelle j'ai un truc à vous
dire il commence par une petite salle
c'est la salle à manger je un piano et
je commence à jouer je vais le faire tu
vas le faire ça j'aurais aimé est un
artiste je commence dans le piège oui
c'est je sais chanter we say je suis il
sait tout ça mais pourquoi je me suis
dégonflé de la faire maintenant parce
que il ya un épisode très important qui
est celui qui va être tranché par la
justice quelques semaines et j'ai pas eu
envie qu à aucun moment je donne
l'impression que j'allais tu vas toucher
cette sorte une angoisse et ce
avant la vente touché la fortune je veux
déjà contraire
je sais bien tu as vu avant le blé je
vais en vie il a été volé parce que j'ai
l'impression vous avez tous oublié tous
obtenant tu vas faire sécession mais
rappelez-vous lui il a écrit un livre il
s'est fait insulter par tout le monde
pour l'avoir fait mais n'oubliez pas que
les affiches collées dans les journaux
français c'était moi qui avait payé le
lyonnais moi tout seul la déconfiture du
lyonnais s'était de tapis avec mon nom
écrit sur une poubelle et le lyonnais
qui disait on a vidé les ordures donc si
tu veux g la première chose très envie
que la france sache par un jugement
parce que le premier jugement qui a été
donné il est passé sous silence est ce
que quelqu'un c'est ici qu'ils ont été
condamnés en première instance à deux
milliards et demi d'arabes non personne
ne le sait le jugement à 5 ans
et pourtant il a fait un livre dans
lequel c'est écrit
sur le comment ils ont tué tapis ouais
mais l'histoire du crédit lyonnais
personnes ça n'a pas été publié et comme
ça a été publié parce que j'arrivais
pages et 10 g d andré sois gentil faire
un livre là-dessus me dit pas de
problème à condition tu me laisses faire
enquête tu me donnes tous les documents
généralement de taille eh ben il lui qui
chaque fois qu'il fait un livre toi ça
donne l'essentiel et ben rien a vite et
l'uil paris l'afp en a vendu combien
60000 voilà c'est pas si mal
dix mois imagine tu viennes le pognon là
la
contrefaçon bateaux en attente ans massa
tu continues le théâtre du fida mans
voilà c'est ça que je voulais ensemble
des rachats tôt m à novembre évidemment
ah ça c'est sûr la l'autre julita 8 jo
bompas
et et thierry entre nous
et là c'est encore là à là je vais te
dira récupère mon argent est encore
difficile à un mois pendant tu prends
basile comme entraîneur n'ont
[Applaudissements]
pas vraiment barder
c'est une bonne qu'à une bonne patate
vannes patate
pas se tenir
ta droite baiser la femme d'un mec
[Musique]
mais aller dans tout paris pour raconter
que tu fais mal pascal thomas dit
ça c'est pas classe dornach l'om ça
pourrait plus être l'om je n'exclus rien
non si tu reviens non je peux pas moi je
suis moi je peux plus retourner moi
pourquoi je vécus simplon de rêve
c'est impossible répond bien sûr qu'en
cameroun ont
le budget de valence
oublie ça
il est 20% mois quel budget de l'om mais
c'est pas ça d'un a aujourd'hui tous les
jeunes même 2,2 les jeunes de qui joue à
sedan ou qui joua à guingamp ils vont
jouer à liverpool reçoit manchester
c'est plus pareil c'est plus pareil
aujourd'hui mais c'était la même et tu
prends à temps non mais c'est plus par
est aujourd'hui l'effectif et de l'om
c'est kristen va il a joué à barcelone
et là je me sens qu elle joue et il
allait si c'est pas ce à quoi il n'y a
plus rien de manière plus rien il ya
bien sûr nous sommes ici j'imagine la
scène n'a touché son pognon à problèmes
moi je
il m'a demandé j'ai ri là il célibat il
avait tu m'as dit oui à foirer
regarde dans les yeux mais regarde moi
j'en laisse le regarde moi dans les yeux
la grosse série regarde droit dans les
yeux que je te dis de venir qui viendra
non non tu vas dit oui azéma l'un des
jeunes lorsqu'ils arrivent à saturation
et puis revient quand il est passé c'est
maintenant je suis à abidjan je suis
tranquille
il est de venir ouais ouais je lui dis
je vais réfléchir on dit jamais non
j'ai dit je vais réfléchir bon
alors là tu vas faire comme dreyfus je
vais dépenser tout en mangeant sur noël
au prix où sont les jouets c'est vrai
que c'est pour ça je suis dit c'est
impossible au chaud
jakez bernard tapie
très enfants bernardin juvénile secret
quand même un pote autant de france qui
trient les trucs
toute façon puisque ça secret je vais
pas vous le dire un jour je vous le
dirai saint brais les produits un truc
ouais et puis je vous dirai si vous
voulez les mêmes c'est cher bernard
tapie va se recycler dans l'anti âge
c'est ça voilà en tout cas ça marche 75
regarde 75 ans
bon alors bernard d'abord merci d'être
là vous n'avez rien de plus un nombre
non et vous êtes là par solidarité pour
tout le monde en parle parce que c'est
l'avant dernière émission
il ya un an membres n'ont cessé il a
quand même il a quand même demandé 30
millions l'équipage je suis quelque
personne même les a donné son nom de
jardin non mais c'est vrai franchement
ça fait vraiment plaisir parce que parce
que c'est une émission qui va manquer
beaucoup c'est donc je suis content de
venir avec vous deux à l'occasion d'un
de ces derniers en dévoile à merci alors
bien sûr on va parler politique on va
commencer avec avec le foot avec le
mondial avec les bleus
[Musique]
messieurs
fini
alors gare à vous expliquer comment
cette métamorphose des bleus dans le
match contre l'espagne il ya plein de
raisons mais on va essayer de sortir les
essentiels la première et la plus
importante c'est le changement total de
psychologie et de motivation quand on
rencontre le togo la corée même la
suisse les français ont beau se dire et
se le dise il faut gagner on va mettre
tout notre coeur me mettre toute notre
énergie ils font appel à ce qu'on
appelle la motivation volontaires celles
qui dépendent sa volonté quand tu
rencontres l'espagne et qu' il s'agit de
passer un cap et surtout de remettre les
pendules à l'heure là c'est tu fais
appel à la motivation inconsciente
celle qui te fait courir le 100 m parce
que ton gosse se noie 1 la vraie
différence à s'éclate qui font ils font
appel à des ressources que seule la
volonté ne peut pas de données alors
quand on sait qu'un être humain utilise
à peine la moitié de ses potentialités
car sur un match comme ça tu obtiens des
trucs bon alors ensuite l'espagne eux
ont vécu le contraire on aura mis la
tête comme ça c'est les futurs champions
du monde ce qui fait que malgré
l'ouverture du score aurait pu leur
permettre de temporiser un peu de jouer
les malades restez derrière évasion de
continuer on continue et ils nous ont
donné des boulevards derrière que les
français ont bien su exploiter ses
énormes c'est énorme parce que on a vu
ce que ça a généré chez les gens c'est
inimaginable
c'est une belle démonstration de ce que
les gens sont capables de faire lorsqu
on leur offre un événement qui verra un
bill at war les gens vivraient en tout
les nerfs français sans variété
incroyable sais pas si tu as eue dans
les rues par tours 1 c'était une c'était
un bonheur exprimé sans limite et qu'on
voit pas dans autres dans d'autres
formes d'existence ce que le sport et en
particulier le football moi je vois
jamais des gens qui se connaissent pas
dans la rue qui s'embrassent et c'est la
grande classe un quartier
ces boîtes privées oui
cette émission est enregistré
exceptionnellement avant france brésil
mais puisqu'on est jeudi soit la voilà
donc tu vas me donner un pronostic
et l'hommage vient de finir c'est
horrible objectivement je ne te juge la
réputation bernard parce que je ne peux
que te dire voilà ce qui va se passer un
sûrement un et te dire je souhaite
tellement j'ai tellement envie qu'on
gagne que je te fais pas de pronostics
je te fais que mon souhait ouais ouais
j'ai vraiment la trouille j'ai vraiment
peur parce que réellement sur le papier
autant il n'ya pas une autre équipe
franchement y'a pas une autre équipe qui
nous est supérieure dit bien sur le
papier sur le papier le brésil nous est
supérieur alors maintenant est ce que
cette espèce de confiance convient de
prendre cette espèce de 2,2 volonté de
ne rien avoir à faire parce que
maintenant ils ont fait l'essentiel on
est en quart de finale contre lundi l'un
celui qui gagnera sera dur à battre le
fait que l'arbitré espagnol
conneries pour nous un difficile
difficile forcément il va se manger les
espagnols arbitres espagnols moi je
pense que y'aura forcément à dire sur
l'arbitrage un malheureux temps c'est
quoi commentant la merde parce que c'est
le coucher du soleil c'est quoi
l'oiseau derrière julien merle mais
c'est génial quand à la tombée du jour
c'est la nar il fait le maire j'étais
jure que non
je ne connais pas les saisons la nature
tout ça tu connais pas sa mère la reine
qui à merde
alors ça répond j'en ai dans mon jardin
ici peut déjà de moreau était l'invité
tous les jours et moi je finis la la la
la la
on est devenus potes
au pensez quoi des condamnations dans le
procès des comptes de l'om marc tapis et
je veux qu'on pense la même chose que
quand elle s'adressait à moi
elles ont strictement aucun sens tu peux
pas condamner robert louis dreyfus pour
abus de bien social dans son club dans
lequel il a mis 130 millions d'euros là
je veux dire faut être un peu que 6 de
fresnes qui peut l'accuser plein de
choses éventuellement d'art fait des
contrats bidons d'avoir arnaqué j'avais
l'urssaf que les joueurs et est pris
chez sur les impôts je suppose qu'il
doit y avoir dans le dossier des choses
mais ils n'ont pas retenu là dessus donc
ça veut dire qu'il était coupable de
rien d'autre que ça et là c'est du
délire on peut pas reprocher à un mec
d'avoir été
puisque le délit d'abus de bien c'est
d'avoir porté tort à son entreprise en
gros en gros tu porteras ton entreprise
quand tu mets 150 millions d'euros dans
les caisses un drôle de mazaugues donc
ça tient pas debout alors à suite si on
veut parler des systèmes qui tourne
autour du foot en france je parle
tous les clubs ont recours aux mêmes
arnaque qui consiste à pouvoir faire des
salaires concurrentiels avec les
étrangers qui paye moins d'impôts voilà
tout le problème est là quand un joueur
est sur le point de venir en angleterre
en espagne en italie ou en france il
choisit un autre pays que le nôtre parce
qu'il est plus taxé alors puisqu'on
parlait tout à l'heure ça va vous
intéresser on parlait tout à l'heure des
pronostics eh bien je vais vous dire
pourquoi la france est devenue un petit
pays de football l'angleterre tous les
joueurs de l'équipe anglaise joue en
angleterre mais qui dit à sauve beckham
l'italie tous les joueurs déclin
italienne journée italie l'espagne tous
les joueurs l'espagne joue en espagne
les allemands tous les joueurs allemands
jouent en allemagne les français trois
joueurs français jouent en france
on a rejoint le peloton des pays sous
développés c'est qu'à cause des impôts y
songer déjà on sait pas que ça c'est
globalement ses impôts c'est les
contrôles c'est l'urssaf c'est un pays
qui devient pays tellement pressurisée
que les gens ont envie d'aller ailleurs
et ce qui se passe dans le football ne
vous faites pas
oh c'est comme ça pour les artistes qui
peuvent partir ailleurs c'est comme ça
pour tous les autres sportifs de haut
niveau c'est comme ça pour les grands
chercheurs c'est comme ça pour les
grands ingénieurs et ça va finir par
être comme ça partout pour tout le monde
que a plus personne peut être est il y
aura six il y aura ceux qui veulent un
attendent des autres leur salut
personnel mais est ce que cette crise de
confiance envers l'équipe de france
finalement ne traduit pas ne reflète pas
une crise de confiance du pays en
lui-même les français sont très bizarre
parce que il rien sondage sur la
croyance le bonheur etc qui m'a
vachement épater ses c'est ça dans le
challenge début de l'année question êtes
vous plutôt heureux plutôt malheureuse
80 2 % des gens plutôt heureux 4
deuxième question pensez vous que les
français sont plutôt heureux malheureux
ils pensent que 82% des français sont
mal
c'est dément un tournant schizophrénie
total ça veut dire que toutes les
nouvelles toutes les infos qu'ils sont
ce qu'elles sont on va pas reprocher aux
journaux télévisés de dire qu' il ya
tant de morts par le sida qu il ya le
tsunami etc n'empêche que leurs
impressions à eux c'est de vivre au
milieu d'une tempête incroyable rêve qui
fait que tout le monde doit être dans
une merde noire on doit souffrir et pas
nous mais c'est pas vrai je veux dire
c'est c'est un des gros problèmes qui
rend ce pays très compliqué à gérer
c'est pour ça que c'est un pays où il ya
un taux de suicide très important c'est
le plus gros consommateurs
d'antidépresseurs au monde la france
très sain ouais c'est vrai qu'au moment
des trente glorieuses on a eu un modèle
social très développé qui était vraiment
bien bien installés qui était basé sur
le partage sur le fait que tout le monde
doit profiter au moins en ce qui
concerne l'éducation la santé la justice
des progrès qui sont faits et puis ils
ont pris pour beaucoup l'habitude d'être
un peu sponsoriser un peu assisté quand
ils se sentent plus dans cette situation
de sécurité beaucoup perdre les pédales
on est aussi un des pays où le divorce
fait le plus de ravages et crée des
situations dramatiques quand un couple
sans moyens divorce cédé il ya des mecs
qui couchent dans la bagnole parce que
il donc de quoi payer un appartement pas
deux
évidemment heureusement on laisse la
femme dans l'appartement avec les
enfants et le mec il a plein au nord
donc en dehors de la souffrance
affective il ya une souffrance matériel
terrible mais il y avait un sondage
d'enlever l'observateur dont on parle d
ici la semaine dernière déjà moi qui me
qui m'étonne complètement c est vous
favorable ou non l économie de marché
alors en chine ses 74 % des chinois sont
favorables à la commune marché aux états
unis ses 71 % dans les grands pays
européens c'est 65 66 % et en france et
34% alors est ce que la france est très
en avance et elle a compris que le
capitalisme s'étaient pas bien et lé
post capitaliste ou au contraire elle
est très en retard il ya un problème
mais d'abord il est possible qu'il
existe un système beaucoup plus efficace
plus généreux qui rend les gens plus
heureux qu'on le connaît pas un puisque
pour l'instant on a mis en opposition le
marxisme a généré un socialiste puis une
social-démocratie et puis la loi du
marché bon encore une fois à la loi du
marché pour les gens c'est l'abandon
d'une certaine sécurité et d'une
certaine protection à peu les gens
commandent un pays le plus protégé
forcément les français sont les plus
opposés à le demeurer
ensuite et à l'interprétation qu'on
serait dans le mot la loi du marché pour
beaucoup la loi du marché c'est la loi
de la jungle et il faut reconnaître que
par certains égards c'est un peu vrai
ouais alors est-ce que le français est
plus malin plus impertinent plus
rigoureux pour exiger davantage c'est un
peu tout ça maintenant il faut que ces
français-là se disent que s'il existe
une autre technique une autre méthode
c'est pas la france qui pourra l'imposé
seul parce qu'elle fait 2 % du monde la
fin donc dans un monde qui est
entièrement soumis à la loi du marché on
est obligé de l'adopter c'est du baratin
alors on a des mecs j'entends besancenot
j'entends tout ça c'est bien c'est c'est
rafraîchissant mais entendent dénoncer
ils font quoi il faut que dalle que la
france est un peu le village d'astérix
aujourd'hui nombre des passes et 1 passe
et vous avez vu qu'il a dit les patrons
faut tous les virer on les remplacera
ouais par quoi par d'autres patrons 1
qui auront une nouvelle hiérarchie toute
la société basée sur une hiérarchie que
tu tues tu mets 150 m
sur une plage tu les laisses un an et
demi tu reviens il ya un patron il ya
deux adjoints puis elle connard en bas
tu veux rien foot ou parce qu'il sait
pas quoi faire et la société doit être
bien organisé parce que celui qui est en
bas il a le droit aussi de vivre ne pas
être piétinée d'être protégé qu'on lui
pique pas son dû pour hubert pas sa
femme il a le droit alors c'est là où la
société doit être organisé pour faire
face à la limite aux aux inégalités de
la hiérarchie minière archi elle existe
dans les pays socialistes y avait une
hiérarchie dans les pays capitalistes
une hiérarchie la france est un pays qui
s'accommode mal des hiérarchies pays
acier égalitariste la france ben on lui
a fait sa conception comme ça sans logis
en tous les cas tout ça donne aux
prochaines élections présidentielles
une importance considérable un oui
falloir faire attention au programme là
parce qu'après abc moi je pense
franchement qu'on n'est pas dans la
situation dramatique qu'on raconte on
n'est pas bien et là il va falloir être
très prudent je crois que cette
injection là sont les dernières où on a
le droit de se tromper alors vous vous
avez pas revenir en politique pourtant
vous êtes éligibles depuis trois ans
mais voudrait parvenir est ce que vous
avez peur vous dit quand je voulais
devenir maire de marseille on a trouvé
100 mille francs dans un jardin pour
m'envoyer en prison l'affairé om va si
je suis candidat à la présidentielle on
va mettre 100 kilos de cocaïne dans mon
coffre 7 passant parce que bon cop ne
tient pas mais quelques kilos n'en rien
c'est une manière de dire qu'on
ne veut pas tout le monde est finalement
bon baisons elles ont ils veulent rester
entre eux c'est un métier de faire de la
politique
les professionnels politiques ont
toujours une distance à l'égard de ceux
qui viennent pas de rang mais c'est vrai
de kouchner c'est vrai de borloo c'est
vrai de tapis c'est vrai de tous ceux
qui à un moment donné ont eu envie de
franchir le pas est-ce que c'est
légitime quelque part oui quelque part
louis parce que on n'a pas donné en tout
cas de gages sur la réalité de nos
convictions notre programmation etc par
conséquent on peut croire que on est
capable de séduire sur des éléments
d'appréciation qui justifient pas un le
vote c'est pour ça que les électeurs
font une grande distinction entre la
côte d'amour avec des sondages
extraordinaire à kouchner oui le vote 1
le vote c'est une opinion la côte
d'amour c'est une humeur ça nous ramène
d'ailleurs à faire attention aux
sondages alors vous n'avez pas revenir
en politique bernard mais vous allez
intervenir d'abord au nom des trois
millions de gens qui ont voté pour vous
tiens là c'est pas pas du sondage
l'allumeur 2008 un essai du butin dans
les journaux et puis peut-être aussi au
nom du parti radical de gauche non c'est
là que je suis parti parce que c'est la
philosophie radicale entre parenthèses
qui est peu développée on a l'impression
qu'il existe plus de 2 mais le
radicalisme c'est justement c est faux
souvenirs c'est gambetta 120 série ces
modèles français l'école le public
obligatoire elle apaise séparation de
l'église et de l'état va se veut dire
c'est des choses importantes le d'ariel
le radicalisme qui privilégie l'homme
plutôt que les systèmes qui met l'homme
au centre de ses préoccupations de ces
débats qui considère qu' un état une
nation n'est forte que par l'addition de
ces valeurs individuelles elle reconnaît
donc la valeur individuelle comme un
élément d'appréciation mais à condition
que les intérêts individuels soient
compatibles avec l'intérêt collectif
normale en termes un peu plus simple ça
veut dire quoi chacun se démerde
chacun essaie d'être le meilleur on doit
pas
envisager une égalité par le bas rhin
mais face à la scolarité donc à
l'apprentissage face à la santé face à
la justice on doit tous et égaux le
chanceux le malchanceux l'intelligent le
compte ou le mont si la république c'est
la république c'est la réponse est ce
qu'on appelle la république alors en
2007 vous croyez vous à un match sarko
ségo
prier pour l'instant il est plus que
probable ouais est-ce que vous avec les
mecs comme l'inde comme fabius comme
strauss kahn et 15 ans les mecs qui sont
là qui rament voudrait qu'ils vont
laisser ségolène royal leur piquer non
seulement je crois et blessé un mais
alors là pour le coup je comprends rien
à la stratégie du parti socialiste rien
c'est le contraire justement de ce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure du radicalisme
l'élection présidentielle c'est un
candidat ou une candidate qui se
présente d'or les français qui fait une
proposition qui dit voilà la société tel
que je l'imaginé et qui s'entoure des
gens pour la mettre en place le parti
socialiste commence à te dire voilà le
programme on se met tous d'accord sur un
programme dont il est tous d'accord pour
dire la même chose et après comme un
casting
comme un film un film tu fais le
scénario et après tu as le metteur en
scène commence à choisir les acteurs
mais c'est de la folie chaque candidat
socialiste à la candidature devrait
faire son programme
passer devant les militants pour que les
militants c'est vrai c'est vrai nom est
un programme et non pas pour un homme ou
une femme sur un improbable c'est ça qui
les amène d'abord à dire n'importe quoi
t'as vu c'est golem et toujours à 1000
même si je vais aller dit qu'il fera
savait déjà mais il y en a pas qui
l'attend y en a pas un qui pense pas
or les sons ségolène royal vendre son
programme celui auquel elle croît 1 si
les militants socialistes en veulent pas
ils peuvent préférer strauss kahn qui
manque pas de qualités qui manquent pas
d'idées ou fabuleuse qui manque pas de
qualités qui manquent pas d'idées et
après par la loi normale de respecter le
vote des militants tout le monde se met
nerfs le candidat et son programme
plutôt que ça alors ta ségolène qui est
pour on sert un peu la vis le parti
socialiste est là on sert pas la lys ta
ségolène qui est pour le mariage nom
déconne pas on est contre le mariage tu
comprends plus rien c'est du délire
sigolène vous la connaissez bien ouais
elle est sympa après elle parle de blair
mais faut pas vous faire d'illusions
elle est socialiste ait away oui oui oui
vrai de vrai alors ce qu'aime sabah à
lézinnes les mecs et que sarkozy vous
êtes copain bernard non plus non non je
les aime bien ouais je le connais on se
connaît est lui aussi c'est un candidat
redoutable mais lui il est dans une
configuration qui est plus facile parce
que l'ump c'est devenu son parti il est
à la fois
prescripteurs des idées de son parti et
récepteurs de ce que le son parti
propose on dit il va nous faire une
programmation qui en main de ce qu'ils
ressentent et des hommes qui vont le
soutenir pour le faire donc là il est
plus à l'aise pour aller devant les
électeurs que quelqu'un qui va défendre
un programme qui n'est pas le sien donc
je dirais que normalement on a plus de
chance alors c'est peut-être une bonne
ou mauvaise chose chaque français fera
ce qu'il veut mais vous avez plus de
chance de voir sarkozy faire ce qui va
dire qu'il va faire un cahier socialiste
que les socialistes parce que lui il a
cessé son programme et a vu que j'espère
revient puis cette semaine oui j'ai vu
ba dans la même semaine on a quand même
eu les résidents qui a annoncé qui dira
s'il est candidat au 1er trimestre 2007
mais et jospin qui nous dit
officiellement ce qui l'a pas arrêté
nous dire faut quand même dire que ça
fait un an qu'ils nous dit un témoin ou
givet et si vous m'appelez je vais y
aller donc on vous rendez compte on va
peut être assister à une un autre
france-brésil quoi
à la limite ça va être de nouveau le
combat des chefs mais non jospin je
crois qu'il se met hors jeu en faisant
ça il se met pas hors jeu en étant
candidat il se met hors jeu en annonçant
qui peut l'être si on va le chercher
parce qu'il aurait pu très bien ne pas
annoncer qu'il était candidat avant
qu'on le demande et là ils avaient une
légitimité quelque part pourquoi d'abord
parce que il croit pas un instant que
ségolène royal est capable il dit pas
qu'elle va pas gagner il estime tout le
monde sait qui la considère pas capable
de prison le république deuxièmement il
pense que les communistes les verts les
extrêmes gauche etc il a à peu près le
seul à pouvoir faire la gauche béria
espèces gauche plurielle donc s'il avait
été effectivement demandé sans qu'ils
disaient c'était crédible mais là ils
leur demandent qu'on l'appelle alors
qu'on le demande pas je crois qu'il
s'est disqualifiée tu vois que les gens
lui en veulent en plus de cette barre en
2002 qua non ils lui en veulent pas de
cette barre en 2002 il a eu une attitude
au contraire honorable j'allais dire
digne minimum que tous les politiques
devraient avoir moi le jour où j'ai été
mis hors la politique pour les ans vous
savez je lui suis mise même si
maintenant je suis éligible 1 je
considère qu'on peut pas dire ben attia
je suis fini je reviens il a été porteur
d'un échec terrible il il en a souffert
terriblement il a eu le seul
comportement digne que tous les hommes
politiques n'auraient pas eu et on
vouloir pour ça allons il a été au
contraire ils ont plaire alors
maintenant si dit attendez et finalement
je vais prévenir nouvelles vannes - là
ça sent un peu le faisandé quand même
alors tapis vous serez candidat de toute
façon dont le film de fabien onteniente
et qui s'appelle le candidat justement
j'ai adoré ce mec s'est rencontré il m'a
dit qu'est ce tu prêt page d'une pièce
comment s'appelle le candidat il m'a dit
non tu fais un film avec moi 1 il est
vraiment génial donc on va faire un film
ensemble à la rentrée la wii et j'ai
bien aimé son approche il à la jane
bonne idée alors j'ai déclaré j'ai connu
la vie avec beaucoup d'argent je la
connais maintenant sans je préfère la
vie avec et bah ça vous étonne pas tout
est mieux c'est vachement mieux c'est
vachement mieux parce que les gens
essaient de mettre en opposition
l'argent et le bonheur par exemple
si tu me dis tu préfères riches ou en
bonne santé ça suppose que tu es riche
et malade oui je préférais être pauvre
en bonne santé mais t'es pas obligé
d'être malade parce que tu es riche un
bon we met donc en bonne santé riche et
en bonne santé fauvre s'est mué en bonne
santé riche mais c'est tout mieux
arrêter de déconner dakar dak'art non
mais vous le balaur mais vous non mais
c'est mieux d'avoir de l'argent dit beau
n'avoir que vous dites maintenant je
connais la vie sans argent ça veut dire
quoi et bien d'avoir un salaire qui
correspond à un salaire de cadre on
n'est pas plus non puisque tout le reste
c'est rigolo
non mais quoi que vous gagnez maintenant
ça ouais et courbier se trouvait qu'il
était trop lourdement condamnés en lan
taele ont mis deux ans de prison ouais
c'est beau père ouais et puis la
récupérer sur site avant il a récupéré
18 mois il a dû faire des choses
vachement grave quand même pour moi
ronnie en prenant trois ans et demi
c'est en progrès ce qu'on donne un type
qui viole dans la rue en courant que
j'essaie donc il a dû faire des trucs
terribles et je crois pas qu'il ait
sénart terrible vous devez bien au long
oui j'aime beaucoup
bernanke a dit on va faire une review
là
bernard vous pensez à quoi en ce moment
je suis bien content de voir ma fille
devoir vous je suis foutu bien quand
vous vous regardez le matin dans la
glace vous dites quoi bernard
le seul moment où je me regarde dans la
glace moment où je me rase et
franchement je me parle pas dans ce
moment là t'as que le samedi dans la
journée d'accord dans la journée ça va
arrive sur bagnols tous je vous dis
allez vas-y mon gars il tord ont par
exemple
vous auriez aimé ressembler à qui quand
vous étiez petit bernard bas comme tout
le monde ça dépend de l'âge à quel âge
pas vers 12 ans là quand on commence à
deux en
12 ans mel ferrer mel ferrer et parce
qu'ils sautaient audrey hepburn j'étais
plus d'elle et ça se comprend notre plus
belle histoire d'amour bah c'est la
seule avec ma femme ça fait 32 dans quel
but
c'est beau 32 ans
est vrai qu'aujourd'hui les gens ont
perdu un peu le sens du couple quoi
c'est la première difficulté ils
divorcent quoi c'est vrai oui mais il ya
des couples c'est vraiment un coup de
bol parce que
tu vois bien il ya des gens pleins de
bonne volonté on va pas se forcer quoi
loin c'est pas quelque chose qui peut
jamais y avoir un peu vouloir la vérité
ça il faut quand même le vous voilà il
faut dire je veux réussir et il ya des
passages difficiles et souvent
s'aperçoit que si tu sur mon fils il en
y mettant un peu du sien obtus repas
voilà nous on a été vraiment vachement
bien pendant vingt ans sans aucun
problème puis on a commencé à rentrer
dans l'habitude et là tu en as eu sauf
un et sophie nous a redonné un coup
incroyable parce qu'on s'est retrouvés
d'un gros parents avec les problèmes
d'un enfant en bas âge et c est là tout
va bien ah ouais super est ce que vous
seriez prêt à tout quitter pour le grand
tellement sûr demain dans la rue vous
tombez sur une base s mais fou d'amour
jeu l'avenir de ma femme j'ai tout avait
déjà fait j'ai arrêté de bosser 1 c'est
à dire quand on s'est connus on a arrêté
l'un et l'autre de bosser on a vécu sur
nos économies et on a vécu neuf mois on
n'a rien fait d'autre rien d'autre que
manger dormir et tagada tsoin
après il est plus de tuniques en beauce
quand est-ce que vous avez pleuré pour
la dernière fois à berlin
quand j'ai vu dans ma loge avait pas les
30000 euros promis
les a mis dans un trou c'est un cheval
au j étais pas j'ai chialé on l'a fait
football ouais tu m'en veux pas vous
changeriez quoi en vous si vous aviez
une baguette magique
ma date de naissance ouais ah ouais
qu'est ce que vous pourriez dire de plus
négatif sur vous
et tu crois pas qu'il en a été si dit
comme ça sans
moi j'ai été gâté quand même on m'a
retiré on m'a privé de mes droits
civiques
on m'a privé nommé droit parental on m'a
interdit de sport on m'a interdit de
politique comme interdits d'affaires m'a
dit vaguement refait thouars un
authentique ils ont cru que j'allais
d'ailleurs par me refaire jamais
il y avait un moment où vous êtes dit je
vais jamais y arriver à me refaire
aurait plusieurs fois
et justement si vous deviez était à
refaire qu'est-ce que vous changeriez le
sexe ah ouais bah oui j'ai connu mec
maintenant j'aimerai connaitre pas
tu as envie de te rattraper
vous seriez vous soyez un peu effet
c'est pour ça que je te dise à
qui avez-vous le plus envie d'épater
dans la vue ah c'est un truc que j'ai
jamais aimé ça hein j'ai jamais aimé et
pathé o bernard je veux donner deux
exemples
j'avais un beau bateau jamais personne
n'a pu monter dessus voir une photo de
l'intérieur de mon bateau on n'était
jamais ailleurs que loin
il a été acheté par une femme on avoue
des chambres à coucher la salle à manger
un ladies et les aidera le pot de
géraniums sur la rn6 à épater
c'est-à-dire non moi j'aime j'aime je
sais pas c'est pas j'aime bien j'aime
bien surprendre j'aime bien être et mais
j'aime bien ça mais j'aime pas épaté
alors deuxième exemple le bateau c'était
le premier c'est quoi le deuxième
exemple mon la maison d'accord personne
est rentré faire des photos dans la
maison si les chiens 8e il n'a pas fait
de photos il a piqué les meubles
qu'est ce que vous feriez si vous restez
24 heures à vivre un crédit
je crois que je réglerai quelques
comptes quand même quand même vrai juste
avant de partir et d'avoir un il y en a
quelques-uns qui sont pas soldés encore
et encore de 3 bourre pif dans l'air et
ouais il ya 2-3 et une tournée à faire
est-ce que vous avez déjà pensé au
suicide oui une fois en prison non non
non c'était dehors et grâce à la
halle à à la présence d'esprit de ma
femme c'est ça s'est pas fait qu'est ce
que la vie vous a appris d'un tapis qui
le pire n'est jamais certain oui
comment aimeriez-vous mourir
ah ouais enterré incinérés un vrai qu'on
va enterrer vivants comme en descente
leur a non non je m'en fous sagement
complète j'ai pas peur de ça du touch
croyants
j'ai pas fait trop de mal enfin
contrairement à ce qu'on a dit a pas
tellement de gens qui ont souffert et
donc à la fin du parcours je pense
qu'ils mirent allait bien il était temps
que tu arrives
des toits
c'est patrick r non je me suis coupé le
doigt avant de venir commenter qu'opel
doit j'ai voulu remettre une appli qui
était pas droite c'est quand le client
soit il est mort et en
valais plus en prison vous repasser par
la case départ et vous toucherez 135
millions d'euros attendez où justement
avec cette affaire des 135 millions là
aujourd'hui je viens d'apprendre que
la cour de cassation qui devait se
prononcer en juillet à début juillet
le premier président a fait un
communiqué pour dire que c'était
reporter en séance plénière au début
octobre donc ça veut dire que tu as
gagné en première instance a gagné en
appel lâchés en cassation si en
cassation tu gagnes tu as gagné tu
récupères le pognon et si tu perds serre
jugés entièrement depuis le début non
non c'est là ça repasse devant une
chambre d'appel alors on appelle à on
revient à l'appel ouais mais ça fera là
donc je safaa faire trois mois de plus
donc ça fera 12 ans et 6 mois chez les
jours s'en fiche c'est sans fin 12 ans
et sim dans la sortie c 135 ans c'est
trop dur et j'ai pas mes tirs dans la
poche rien toi c'est gras dans dans les
poches de l'état
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater le in
auditive abonnez vous il m'était
impossible ou